sie ist die erste Autorin die
Milliardären geworden ist
es gibt nicht viele Autoren die immer
Bücher in Serie herausbringt die sich
alle am ersten Tag zwölf 15 Millionen
Mal verkaufen
ihre Vorstellungskraft hat Kinder und
Erwachsene begeistert und jede Branche
verändert die sie berührte Harry Potter
selbst war so groß wie ein kleiner
Verlag
Harry Potter ist das Maß aller Dinge es
ist das größte Film Franchise aller
Zeiten aber JK Rowlings märchenhafte
Erfolg wurde aus Überlebenskampf und
Herzschmerz geboren
ich war arbeitslos und alleinerziehend
ich war die größte Versagerin die ich
kannte mit einem Ende wie aus dem
Bilderbuch Kapitel 1
Mittelpunkt der finanziell
erfolgreichsten Erzählungen der
Geschichte der Belletristik Harry Potter
steht die einzigartige und entschlossene
Joanne rowling
um die 400 Millionen Exemplare in den
Vereinigten Staaten und brachte eine
Milliarde Kinder dazu 4 5 600 seitige
Wälzer zu lesen und das in einer Zeit in
der Kinder überhaupt keine Bücher mehr
Blasen
mit wohl über 10 Milliarden Dollar an
Gesamteinnahmen ist das ein absolut
erstaunliches Franchise dass wir meiner
Meinung nach nie wieder sehen werden
die Popularität von Harry Potter hat
rowling in die ungewohnte Welt der
Berühmtheit katapultiert nachdem sie
einst vom Paparazzi gejagt wurde
schränkt sie heute den Zugang zu ihrem
Privatleben ein und lehnte es ab an
dieser Dokumentation mitzuwirken
Joanne rowling wurde 1965 entlaster
Shire England geboren Schauspieler
jimdail der von rolling als Sprecher für
die Harry Potter Hörbücher in den
Vereinigten Staaten ausgewählt wurde
kannte diese ländlichen Dörfer gut
in diesem kleinen Städten lebten keine
reichen Menschen alle gehörten zur
Arbeiterklasse man gingen die Häuser und
sah dieselbe Tapete die man selbst hatte
denn es gab nur ein einziges
tapetengeschäft in der Stadt es gab nur
einen Genossenschaftsladen dass das
gleiche Kleid dass die eigene Mutter
trug auch von zwei oder drei anderen
Frauen getragen wurde das ist also die
Art von Umgebung rollings literarische
Ambitionen wurden schon früher erkannt
ihr erstes Buch mit dem Titel Hase
stellte sie mit sechs Jahren fertig
Melissa Nelly interviewte rolling für
ihr Buch Harry eine Geschichte voller
Magie
es ging um einen Kaninchen das krank
wird und bei all seinen anderen Hasen
ist und als er es fertig hatte brachte
sie es anscheinend ihrer Mutter und
sagte nun veröffentliche es wird daraus
jetzt etwa kein Buch gemacht
doch hinter dem Selbstvertrauen verbaggt
sich Unsicherheit wie rolling bei Oprah
gestammt ich bin kein Mensch mit viel
Selbstbewusstsein ich war niemand mit
besonders viel von irgendwas ich würde
sogar sagen ich war jemand mit wenig
Selbstvertrauen und doch glaubte ich an
diese eine Sache in meinem Leben das war
die eine Sache in meinem Leben ich
fühlte dass ich eine Geschichte erzählen
kann ihre Geschichte wurde in tascal
einem kleinen Dorf in der Grafschaft
lasterscher geschrieben Tanja arbeitete
als Produzentin bei den ersten vier
Harry Potter-Filmen eng mit rolling
zusammen sie hatte sowohl eine
mikroskopischen als auch einen
mikrokosmischen Blick auf Hogwarts im
Harry Potter Universum sie war im Westen
des Landes aufgewachsen in der Nähe des
Waldes von Wien wo auch ich einen
Großteil meiner Kindheit verbracht hatte
wir hatten also eine Menge gemeinsamer
Bezugspunkte
alles worüber JK in ihren Büchern
schreibt findet sich irgendwo in England
wieder das muss so sein wir haben die
fantastischen alten Schlösser wir haben
diese wunderbaren alten Gebäude
wir haben diese Wälder die man anhand
ihrer Beschreibung selbst kennt oder
dort in der Nähe finden kann wo sie eins
gelebt hat
1980 wurde bei ihrer Mutter Multiple
Sklerose diagnostiziert ein tragisches
Ereignis für die Familie doch das hielt
rolling nicht davon ab an ihrer
Leidenschaft für die Belletristik weiter
festzuhalten wieder in der Schule noch
später am College joe hat in Exeter
Klassik studiert da kommt alles her ihre
klassische Bildung findet sich in den
Harry Potter-Büchern wieder die
griechischen Mythen die christlichen
Allegorien
nach dem College bezahlte rolling ihre
Miete indem sie bei Amnesty
International in London arbeitete wo sie
in ihrer Mittagspause Geschichten
schrieb
1990 hat sie dann in einem Zug nach
London eine Idee die ihr Leben verändern
sollte
dazu blieb stehen und ihr kam
buchstäblich in den Kopf Zauberer Junge
der nicht weiß dass er ein Zauberer ist
geht auf eine Zauberer Schule und weil
sie keinen Stift hatte saß sie
stundenlang da und dachte nach während
der Zug weiter da stand sie fing damit
an der Schule einen Namen zu geben sich
Gedanken über die Lehrer zu machen in
Harry Potter und ich erklärt sie was das
für ein lebensverändernder Moment
gewesen ist dieses unglaubliche Kribbeln
dass man bekommt wenn man gerade
jemanden kennengelernt hat indem man
sich vielleicht verlieben wird
die ganze Harry Welt war ihre
Leidenschaft das Ausmaß in dem dieser
enzyklopädische lebendige Verstand
wusste was hinter einer Tür sein würde
von der man noch nicht einmal wusste
dass es überhaupt gab war wirklich
erstaunlich nur sechs Monate später
erhielt sie eine herzzerreißende
Nachricht
ihre Mutter war an Multiple Sklerose
verstorben
rolling sprach mit der BBC über ihren
Verlust
ich habe sechs Monate vor ihrem Tod mit
dem Schreiben von Harry begonnen das ist
das ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich weil
ich ihr nie gesagt habe dass ich
überhaupt schreibe sie hat also nie
etwas von Harry Potter erfahren
der Tod von Joes Mutter hat sich auf ihr
gesamtes schreiben ausgewirkt auf jede
einzelne Seite von Harry Potter er hat
ihre Ansichten von Liebe und Tod
verändert und davon was es bedeutet wenn
uns jemand verlässt und welche
Auswirkungen das auf unser Leben hat sie
konzentrierte sich zunehmend auf den
zauberjungen und wurde schließlich von
mehreren Jobs gefeuert weil sie schrieb
anstatt zu arbeiten das war eine dunkle
Zeit für die arbeitslose Autoren rolling
beschloss England ganz zu verlassen
Joanne rolling verließ England um in
Porto Portugal einen Neuanfang zu machen
sie bekam einen Job als Lehrerin und
schrieb nebenher weiter
rolling heiratete eine lokalen
Fernsehjournalisten und bekam innerhalb
eines Jahres eine Tochter aber nach
einer wie sie es nannte kurzen und
katastrophalen Ehe zog sie nach
Edinburgh Schottland um in der Nähe
ihrer Schwester zu sein
als ich glaube sie fühlte sich ein
bisschen als Versagerin weil sie arm war
weil sie sehr gut ausgebildet war aber
bisher einfach keine Karriere gemacht
hatte sie versuchte einen Job als
Lehrerin zu bekommen aber die Arbeit war
nicht beständig und so musste sie
öffentliche Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen sie
lebte von der Hand in den Mund von Tag
zu Tag in absolute Armut am
Existenzminimum es ist nicht glamourös
und nicht romantisch aber es hat dazu
beigetragen dass dieses Buch
letztendlich in Produktion ging
rolling sagte dass der Tiefpunkt die
Grundlage für den Wiederaufbau ihres
Lebens war
eines Cafés weiter während ihre Tochter
neben ihr schlief
[Musik]
und als sie die ersten drei Kapitel
hatte mit denen sie zufrieden war
schickte sie sie an einen Agenten
es wurde abgelehnt in 1995 schickte sie
drei Kapitel an die Agentur von Chris
little dort wurde es genauso behandelt
wie es für Werke unbekannte Autoren
üblich war wie little in Sixty minutes
erzählte
diese Dinge können ewig auf einem Stapel
liegen man nennt ihn auch den
matschhaufen aber wie ist der Zufall
wollte nahm ich zwei Tage später diesen
Stapel in die Hand und nahm ihn mit zum
Mittagessen weil meine Begleitung spät
dran war und drinnen begann ich von
Harry Potter zu lesen und sie stellten
sich die Nackenhaare auf aber 12
Verleger lehnten das Buch ab
niemand wollte weil es damals politisch
unkorrekt war Internate zu bewerben es
war zweimal so lang wie ein Kinderbuch
sein durfte es hatte diesen ellenlangen
Titel Harry Potter und der Stein der
Weisen es war genau das was Verleger
damals nicht an Büchern haben wollten
und so brachte er es nicht an den Mann
das Buch von schließlich seinen Weg zu
einem neuen Kinderbuchverlag namens
Bloomsbury
ist medienanalyst und ehemaliger
Verleger
die Tochter des Geschäftsführers hat die
ersten beiden Kapitel gelesen ging zu
ihrem Vater und sagte sie wolle mehr
davon lesen das ist eben auch das schöne
am Verlagswesen es geht zu einem großen
Teil ums Bauchgefühl
[Musik]
1996 6 Jahre nach dem rolling mit dem
Schreiben von Harry Potter begonnen
hatte Boot Bloomsbury ihr 4000 $ für das
Buch an das war nicht viel aber für
rolling war es magisch Magic der Moment
in dem man mir sagte dass Bloomsbury das
Buch übernehmen wollte war nach der
Geburt meiner Tochter der glücklichste
Moment meines Lebens
aber es gab einen Haken um die
Marktfähigkeit zu verbessern wollte
Bloomsbury dass sie ihren Namen in etwas
geschlechtsneutrales ändert die little
in Sixty minutes erklärte
traditionell lesen Jungs nicht gerne
Bücher die von Mädchen geschrieben
wurden Mädchen ist es egal wer die
Bücher geschrieben hat aber Jungs haben
diese seltsame sexistische Einstellung
Joanne Liese ich von ihrer Großmutter
Kathleen eine mittlere initiale und
wurde JK Rowling
auf der Buchmesse in Bologna 1997 sprach
sich das Buch schnell herum
rafaele Wien Vizepräsident von skolastik
war dorthin geflogen um nach etwas
Besonderem zu suchen
ich wollte Bücher finden die nicht nur
im Trend liegen oder gerade populär sind
sondern die von den Kindern wirklich
geliebt und ihre Lieblingsbücher werden
Michael Jacobs war zu diesem Zeitpunkt
zehn Jahre weiß Präsident der
Handelsabteilung von skolastik
es war sicherlich ein Buch das in
Bologna viel Aufsehen erregt hat und ich
glaube für AfA war es ziemlich
offensichtlich dass das Buch das
Potenzial für eine Serie hatte aber das
erste Buch war schon an und für sich
außergewöhnlich
eine beispiellose Summe von 105.000 für
die amerikanischen rechte Hand im ersten
Harry Potter Buch
als Joe den Anruf von Christopher little
erhielt der ihr sagte dass ihr Buch für
105.000 Dollar nach Amerika verkauft
wurde sagte sie dass sie zum ersten Mal
sehr erschrocken war es war einfach
überwältigend um ehrlich zu sein hatte
mich das Leben in den letzten Jahren so
sehr gebeutelt dass ich ziemlich
misstrauisch war wenn ich gute
Nachrichten erhielt die guten
Nachrichten wurden mehr 1997 wurde das
Buch in Großbritannien veröffentlicht
und wurde zum Erfolg
die erste Generation der Schulhof Potter
Fans war geboren
Joanne Rowlings zweites Buch war bereits
in Arbeit nachdem der erste Harry Potter
zu einem Spitzenpreis ans golistik
verkauft worden war sie spürte einen
enormen Druck den Schwung beizubehalten
der Verkauf nach Amerika war in England
eine große Sache eine unbekannte
britische Autorin verkauft ihr erstes
Buch auf dem amerikanischen Markt der im
Gegensatz zum englischen Markt 5 oder 6
mal so groß ist es war wie die
Geschichte vom tellerwäsche eine arme
Autorin wurde zum Millionärin die
amerikanischen Verleger hofften dass
Harry Potter abliefern wurde
wir wussten dass wir etwas Besonderes in
den Händen hielten und das wussten wir
schon ziemlich früh unser Ansatz war
also wirklich ist wie einen Blockbuster
zu veröffentlichen
[Applaus]
eine Art spezial-einsatzkommando dass
sich jede Woche wegen Harry Potter traf
sculastik entschied sich für einen
interaktiven Ansatz zur Vermarktung des
Buches
wir haben das Buch einigen auserwählten
vor Veröffentlichung zum Lesen gegeben
ich glaube einige von ihnen haben
rolling sogar treffen dürfen bevor das
Buch überhaupt veröffentlicht wurde auf
diese Weise haben wir also einen riesen
Wirbel ausgelöst und als das Buch dann
in den Verkauf ging verbreitete es sich
wie ein Lauffeuer Harry Potter und der
Stein der Weisen verkaufte sich in 10
Monaten über 800.000 Mal und stand über
ein Jahr lang auf der Bestsellerliste
der New York Times
als der zweite Teil 1999 in den USA die
Läden kam wurde die Veröffentlichung der
Porta Bücher zu einem großen Ereignis
zog die Öffentlichkeit in seinen Bann
[Applaus]
veranstalteten zu jedem neuen Titel der
herauskam ein Spektakel seit dem
buchstäblich Tausende von Kindern vor
den Buchläden standen meistens Kostüm
mitten in der Nacht um ein Exemplar
abzubekommen
Logistik an einem Tag 10 oder 11
Millionen Exemplare eines Buches auf den
Markt zu bringen war schwierig wie sie
sich sicher vorstellen können die Bücher
zu transportieren dafür zu sorgen dass
sie sicher und verschlossen waren sicher
zu stellen dass die Bücher niemandem in
die Hände fielen bevor sie in jedermanns
Hände gelangten die Verkaufszahlen jedes
einzelnen Buches stiegen exponentiell an
die erste Auflagen wurden viel viel
größer die einzige dunkle Wolke die
einen Schatten auf das wachsende
Phänomen warf waren Proteste
konservative religiöser Gruppen die in
den mystischen Geschichten das Böse
sahen sie beschuldigten rolling Hexerei
und Okkultismus zu fördern und
verbrannten ihre Bücher
[Musik]
auch wenn Harry Potter gerade die Welt
im Sturm erobert hat ist Hexerei keine
Produktion und keine Fantasie Hexerei
ist real der Teufel ist real
wenn die Leute der Meinung sind das
Hexerei in Kinderbüchern per se nichts
zu suchen hat dann ist die Debatte
wirklich sinnlos denn viele klassische
Kinderbücher würden aus den
bibliotheksregalen verschwinden wie der
Zauberer von Oz
selbst Kardinal Josef Ratzinger jetzt
Papst Benedikt x hatte seine eigenen
Vorbehalte und die amerikanische
bibliotheksvereinigung führte rollings
Buch als den am meisten angefochtenen
Text in den Vereinigten Staaten an
dieser Gegenwind hatte allerdings keinen
Einfluss auf die Verkaufszahlen die
anhaltende Vorherrschaft von Harry
Potter auf der Bestsellerliste der New
York Times zwang die Zeitung schließlich
dazu eine eigene Kategorie für
Kinderbücher einzuführen ich bin mir
sicher dass unsere Konkurrenten
glücklich darüber waren dass sie wieder
mehr Plätze auf der Beste für sich
beanspruchen können denn wir hätten
wahrscheinlich mit den ersten fünf
Büchern die Top 5 dominiert
sogar die hörbuchverkäufe brachen
Rekorde und verzauberten die Fans wie
Erzähler jimdale nach einer Live Lesung
in New York feststellte
400 Kinder und Mütter waren da und ein
Kind schrieb plötzlich auf du hast einen
Satz ausgelassen als ob es der größte
Fehler wäre und die Mutter sagte bitte
entschuldigen Sie ihn aber er hat das
ganze Buch auswendig gelernt und aus dem
Publikum hörte ich andere kleine Stimmen
sagen ich auch ich auch aber wahr
internationale Vertriebe schnappten sich
die Rechte zu Übersetzung der Bücher und
Harry Potter wurde zu einer weltweiten
Sensation
[Musik]
die Nachfrage wurde so groß dass für die
Marke Harry Potter die Gefahr bestand
außer Kontrolle zu geraten
Supermarkt wir hatten Supermärkte
Lebensmittelläden Tankstellen und andere
Einzelhändler die plötzlich Harry Potter
Bücher haben wollten um den Umsatz
anzukurbeln als Lockvogelangebot für Ihr
Geschäft okay
rowling lehnte hunderte von
lizenzangeboten von Sony Microsoft und
Boeing ab blieb aber ihrer Vision treu
wie sie hier in Sixty minutes erzählte
hier und Sex wenn die Leute sehen
könnten was für Angebote ich bekommen
habe um Harry in Werbung und jeder Menge
lächerlicher Dinge nutzen zu dürfen ich
habe ausnahmslos alle abgelehnt
Absolution aber es gab ein Angebot aus
Hollywood dass sie nicht ablehnen konnte
und ein Filmstudio war dabei
herauszufinden dass Harry Potter wahre
Wunder bewirken könnte ich arbeitete für
eine neue Produktionsfirma von David
Hayman der zu mir sagte nun ich lass
einen Zeitungsartikel in dem stand dass
jemand das erste Buch einer
siebenteiligen Serie über einen kleinen
Jungen geschrieben hatte der auf ein
Internat geht und entdeckt dass er ein
Zauberer ist ich mich also mit ihrem
Agenten traf und versuchte ihn davon zu
überzeugen uns das Buch zu verkaufen
traten wir als Warner Brothers auf hold
the garderidian ist Präsident des
kinoraissance von Hollywood.com
[Musik]
ich glaube für Warner Brothers war es
eine Mission das Harry Potter Franchise
zu bekommen ich meine Warner Brothers
hatte großen Erfolg mit dem Batman
Franchise mit dem Matrix Franchise und
ich glaube sie waren fest entschlossen
ist zu schaffen und ich glaube deshalb
haben sie Jackie rowling so viel
Spielraum gegeben was ihre Kontrolle
über diesen Prozess und über die
Filmreihe angeht sorry unser erstes
Treffen mit j.k rowling fand bei
Mittagessen statt david und ich hatten
ihr ein wenig darüber erzählt was wir
mit dem Film machen wollten und sie
setzte sich mit uns zusammen wir
versuchten verzweifelt sie zu
beeindrucken sie brauchte uns natürlich
nicht zu beeindrucken denn das hatte sie
bereits getan Jackie rolling hat
angeblich 2 Millionen Dollar von Warner
Brothers für die Rechte an den ersten
vier Filmen erhalten
es gibt nicht viele Autorinnen und
Autoren die immer wieder Bücher eine
Serie herausbringen die sich alle am
ersten Tag ziehen 12 15 Millionen Mal
verkaufen das gab wie eine Menge
Einfluss so konnte sie verlangen dass
der Film in Großbritannien mit einer
rein britischen Besetzung gedreht wird
und dass sie sowohl bei der Auswahl der
Schauspieler als auch der Regisseure ein
Wort mit zu reden hatte
top-regisseure bulten um Zutritt zu
rollings imaginärer Welt nun ich weiß
dass man an Steven Spielberg herantragt
um beim ersten Harry Potter Film Regie
zu führen er wollte ihn eigentlich als
Animationsfilm machen aber das kam nicht
zustande und so sprang Chris Columbus
ein Produzent David haimen stellte die
handverlesene Besetzung in einem Warner
Brothers Video vor
Wahl von drei wunderbaren britischen
Schauspielern für die Hauptrollen zeigt
wie gut er den Geist dieser Bücher
versteht ich glaube ihr wichtigstes
Anliegen bei der Verfilmung ihrer Vision
war dass wir den Büchern treu bleiben
ich glaube sie hatte wirklich
unglaublich hart daran gearbeitet
Charaktere in einer Geschichte zu
erschaffen an die sie glaubte und sie
wollte nicht dass das zerhackt und
falsch interpretiert wird
die größte Herausforderung dabei j.k
Rowlings Vision auf die Leinwand zu
kriegen bestand darin dass zu dem
Zeitpunkt als wir finden bereits jeder
das Buch gelesen hatte
hätten sie sich das jemals erträumen
können nicht in einer Millionen Jahren
das war das letzte was ich erwartet
hatte der erste Harry Potter Film kam im
November 2001 in die Kinos wieder einmal
bewirkte der zauberjunge wunder
wunderschön
mit 90,3 Millionen eingespielten Dollar
war es das erfolgreichste
Eröffnungswochenende des Jahres der Film
spielte anschließend 317 Millionen
Dollar ein und war damit der größte
einspielerfolg an den heimischen
Kinokassen im Jahr 2001
rolling behielt nicht nur die kreative
Kontrolle sondern handelte auch einen
unbekannten Prozentsatz der Film und
lizenzgewinne aus
viel wichtiger ist aber dass sie mit dem
Endprodukt zufrieden war
gestern ich glaube als ich ihre Reaktion
auf die fertigen Filme sah habe ich
gedacht wir haben es geschafft es ist
alles in Ordnung wir haben Sie nicht im
Stich gelassen
2001 war auch das Jahr in dem Joanne
rowling ihren zweiten Mann Doktor Neil
Michael Mary heiratete
und die Harry Potter Filme sind
weiterhin ein Kassenschlager
jeder Harry Potter Film stieg zum Start
auf Platz 1 der Kinocharts die Filmreihe
hat einen perfekten Eröffnungswochenende
Rekord aufgestellt wir reden hier über
ein Jahrzehnt wir reden über sieben
Filme
[Musik]
das ein Spielergebnis der sieben Harry
Potter Filme ohne den zweiten Teil von
die Heiligtümer des Todes liegt bei 6,4
Milliarden Dollar da sind Heimvideos
Fanartikel jegliche Art von Soundtracks
und alles andere noch nicht einmal mit
eingerechnet es ist das größte Film
Franchise aller Zeiten
[Musik]
rolling erhält auch einen Anteil an den
Verkäufen der Harry Potter Spielzeuge
von Mattel und ihr Fanartikel Imperium
expandiert weiter
one das ist schwer etwas zu finden das
nicht irgendwann einmal mit einem Harry
Potter Bild versehen war sei es in der
Gaming Spielzeug oder sogar
Bekleidungsbranche das ist eine Norma
Erfolg
2010 bekam Harry Potter seinen eigenen
Themenpark in den Universal Studios in
Orlando der den Namen The Wizarding
World of Harry Potter trägt
und wieder einmal drückte rowling allem
ihren persönlichen Stempel auf vom
Schnee auf dem Dach bis zum Geschmack
des butterbiers sie haben wirklich alle
Zutaten eingetütet sind nach Edinburgh
gefahren haben es hergestellt und dass
ihr präsentiert
sie hat zwei weitere Kinder bekommen und
lebt jetzt auf einem pastoralen Land gut
in Nordschottland
und fünf Jahre nach dem letzten
Wörterbuch veröffentlichte rowling einen
neuen Roman für Erwachsene
ich bin von Drachen und Einhörnern und
all dem Spaß der mit dem Schreiben
dieser Dinge verbunden ist zu einem Buch
übergegangen das sehr persönlich ist und
viel von meiner Realität ausdrückt ja
das Buch mit dem Titel ein plötzlicher
Todesfall wirkte nicht den gleichen
Zauber auf Kritiker wurde aber trotzdem
zur Nummer 1 auf den Bestsellerlisten
rolling hat Erfolg in der literarischen
Welt neu definiert
ihr Nettovermögen wird auf fast eine
Milliarde Dollar geschätzt womit sie zu
den reichsten Frauen der Welt gehört
[Musik]
sie hat sich zu einer wunderbaren Marke
entwickelt was ihre Statur ihre Ethik
und ihr Verhalten angeht
ihre Großzügigkeit erstreckt sich auf
Wohltätigkeitsorganisationen zur
Unterstützung von Kindern
alleinerziehende Eltern armen Menschen
und die multiple sklerosef-forschung
17 Jahre lang hat rowling Harry Potter
gelebt und geatmet ihre Geschichte war
ähnlich wie seine von der Überwindung
schreckliche Herausforderungen auf dem
Weg zur außergewöhnlichen Erfolg geprägt
wie sie 2008 der Harvard Abschlussklasse
erzählte zu wissen dass man aus
Rückschlägen weiser und stärker
hervorgegangen ist bedeutet dass man
sich seiner Fähigkeit zu überleben immer
sicher sein kann man wird sich selbst
oder die Stärke seiner Beziehung erst
dann wirklich kennen wenn beides durch
Widrigkeiten auf die Probe gestellt
wurde ein solches Wissen ist ein wahres
Geschenk denn es war schmerzhaft
errungen und es war mehr wert als jede
qu alifikation die ich jemals erworben
habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er war nur eins dieser Straßenkinder
jetzt ist er ein Geschäftsführer mit
einem globalen 450 Millionen Dollar
Imperium ich glaube nicht dass JC jemals
nur ein Musiker war er dachte er ich
werde das Jay Z Unternehmen aufbauen
niemand hätte gedacht dass er so weit
kommen würde dass er Clubs und
Modelinien besitzen würde und alles
andere was er tut er hat damit geprallt
über die Grenzen der Musik hinauszugehen
und das ist ihm gelungen
übergegangen er nahm den ganzen
Mainstream und kaufte Ihnen eine
Eintrittskarte in seine Welt
er entkam den dunklen Weg den so viele
andere genommen hatten
es passiert die ganze Zeit in diesem
Wohnprojekt du hast ein bestimmtes Leben
und es wird nirgendwohin das führt
entweder ins Gefängnis oder es wird zum
Tod seine Überlebensfähigkeit und
Selbstdarstellung führten ihn auf die
Reise seines Lebens
er ging von der Straßenecke zum Eckbüro
als Chef das war bahnbrechend
ist ein brillanter-texter er ist ein
skrupelloser Geschäftsmann und jemand
den jedes große Unternehmen gerne an der
Spitze haben würde
hatte diese schrittweise aber sehr
tiefgreifende Entwicklung vom Stricher
zum Chef und zu dieser phänomenalen Hip
Hop Größe
anstatt nur irgendeiner zu sein hat er
sich zum Ziel gesetzt der eine zu sein
und das ist einfach eine unglaubliche
Leistung zu sagen ich bin nicht einer
sondern der eine
und das ist er der unbeholfene Junge auf
dem klassenportrait
seater der zum Megastar Jason
unseren Programm nicht teilnehmen
69 in Brooklyn New York geboren und war
das jüngste von vier Kindern
Autor Jack Brown
er kam aus der Hölle aus seinem
Kriegsgebiet das war dieser Wohnkomplex
morsey projects in den 80ern die
Tatsache dass er das überlebt hat so
glaubwürdig im Spiel zu bleiben ist der
einzigartig
Rapper Kollege und früher Mentor jazzo
lebte im selben Wohnprojekt
wir haben mit viel Gewalt zu tun gehabt
wissen sie viel mords Drogenhandel
Drogenmissbrauch
das war ein Glück für einige von uns
daraus zu kommen aber viele die
bekannten haben es nie geschafft
seine Musik handelte von seiner bewegten
Vergangenheit aber er sprach selten
darüber sein offenes einstündiges
Interview mit Charlie Rose im Jahr 2007
war eine Ausnahme
die Dinge die in diesen Vierteln an
einem Tag passiert sind erleben andere
in ihrem ganzen Leben nicht ich habe
einen Blick auf dieses Leben geworfen
was mir hätte passieren können wenn ich
auf der Straße geblieben wäre
sie spielen russisches Roulette mit
ihrem Leben jeden Tag 365 Tage im Jahr
irgendwann knallst du so ist das
gab immer eine Beerdigung
in der sechsten Klasse
diese Kinder sind mit Schusswunden ins
Bett gegangen wenn sie in meinen
Klassenzimmer kamen dösten viele von
ihnen und ich ließ sie weil ich wusste
dass sie die halbe Nacht wach waren
nie vergessen er war schüchtern und
extrem aufgeweckt er war
überdurchschnittlich gut im Lesen er
hatte diese angeborene Fähigkeit
später rebte er darüber gute Noten zu
bekommen aber dass er tief in seinem
Inneren Dämonen hatte die aufgeweckt
wurden er lächelte selten und ich weiß
nicht ob es Traurigkeit war oder einfach
nur seine Persönlichkeit aber er war
immer irgendwie gelassen und lächelte
nicht
als Jay Z elf Jahre alt war verließ sein
Vater die Familie in seinem Song
December Force sein Geburtsdatum
schreibt er er sei ein zerrissenes Kind
Musik Journalist Seck ummely Greenberg
ich glaube das hat Jaycee irgendwie kalt
gemacht und isoliert er war sehr
verletzt und ich glaube das hat ihn zu
dem berechnenden Geschäftsmann gemacht
er heute ist Unsinn im mental
seine Texte spiegeln Distanz wieder und
manchmal
wuti sagt in seinen eigenen Songs er
habe seinen Bruder in die Schulter
geschossen weil er ein Schmuckstück
gestohlen hat
das Geld war knapp für seine
alleinerziehende berufstätige Mutter und
es gab nur wenige Jobs für einen
Teenager
aber der Drogenhandel brachte das
schnelle Geld
die James dass sie ein führender New
Yorker DJ
es ging darum schnell große Summen
Bargeld zu haben und niemandem
Rechenschaft ablegen zu müssen
im Grunde ging es darum Geld zu
verdienen so gut wir konnten und als er
jung war war das halt Crack verkaufen
auf der Straße
Barry Michael Cooper Journalist und
Filmemacher
es ist eigentlich seltsam der
crack-verkauf hat ihm beigebracht
Unternehmer zu sein die Bedürfnisse und
Wünsche der Leute zu verstehen und eine
Nische in dieser trümmerwelt zu finden
seine Liebe zur Welt der Platten begann
zu Hause
seine Mutter hatte diese Plattensammlung
die in der Gegend legendär war und jeder
kam immer um Musik zu hören
er hat ein enzyklopädisches Wissen über
alle möglichen Musikstile
es ist nicht nur Hip Hop Marvin gay
Curtis Mayfield
James Brown natürlich
aber auch Rock and Roll die Stones
[Musik]
Jay bekam keine musikalische Ausbildung
hatte aber instinktiv das Gefühl das
rappt seinen Weg aus diesem Leben sein
könnte er schrieb Texte auch Servietten
auf Papiertüten es strömte aus ihm
heraus
er hat gesagt dass er sieben oder acht
neue Songs gleichzeitig im Kopf
speichern kann das sagt wirklich etwas
über die Datenmenge aus die er
verarbeiten kann
war eher ein sehr schneller Rapper
aber seine Rap-Songs hatten auch
Melodien das war einzigartig zu der Zeit
ich habe vom ersten Tag an an ihn
geglaubt er war 15 wir räumten und wir
fingen an zu vibrieren ich hörte dass er
pures talenta das ist einfach Talent in
seiner reinsten Form
als erster Rapper bei IMI Records unter
Vertrag 1988 nahm er in London das Album
world to the jazz auf er nahm den
18-Jährigen Jason mit und stellte ihm
diesen Song vor
das Album hatte keinen Erfolg und Jessie
kehrte nach Hause zurück
seit kurzer Ausflug in die
Plattenindustrie war eine Enttäuschung
hatte ihm aber die Augen für eine viel
größere Welt geöffnet er war fokussiert
genug um zu sagen weißt du was ich kann
das nicht ewig machen mit drogendealen
denn das kann nur auf zwei Arten Enden
entweder du stirbst oder du gehst ins
Gefängnis
ich hatte tolle Leute um mich herum als
ich an dieser Weg Gabelung stand soll
ich Entertainer werden oder auf der
Straße bleiben ich habe mich entschieden
Entertainer zu werden und es hat
geklappt ich habe den richtigen Weg
eingeschlagen und habe es nie bereut
er machte sich in einer anderen Art von
Straßenschlacht einen Namen
es gab Webcam auf der Straße wie
Nahkämpfe Acapella einfach aufeinander
losgehen und so hat sich Jay durch die
Straßenschlachten einen Namen gemacht
und alle dachten wer ist dieser Typ und
da fing es eigentlich an
er trat jahrelang auf Partys und in
Clubs auf bekam aber keinen
Plattenvertrag frustriert schlug er
einen anderen Weg ein
ich war von Anfang an gezwungen
Führungskraft zu sein denn ich musste
versuchen einen Vertrag zu bekommen
bekam aber keinen ich ging zu jedem
einzelnen Plattenlabel und bekam keinen
Deal also hieß es entweder aufgeben und
zurück auf die Straße gehen oder mir
einen eigenen Weg schaffen um gehört zu
werden
1994 lernte jayce kennen der gerade erst
im Künstlermanagement angefangen hatte
das war damals ein junger Unternehmer
der vor allem Werbung für Partys machte
aber er managt da auch einzelne
Auftritte
wenn man Dash setzte große Hoffnung auf
den 24-Jährigen jayz sie gründeten ihr
eigenes Label Rockefeller Records mit
einer dritten Partnerin Corinne
sie druckten ihre eigenen CDs machten
Werbung packten Aufkleber an Club Türen
sie fuhren durch die Stadt und
verkauften die CDs aus dem Kofferraum
1995 wusste jeder in New York alles über
Hip Hop und wusste auch wer Jazzy war
Rockefeller hat es auf seine Weise
gemacht sie finanzierten ihre Videos
selbst auch viele ihrer Touren weil sie
wussten die mehr Geld Sie ausgeben
würden sie auch für sich behalten
es waren ihre Gewinne das war es was er
wollte sein Geschäft das Rockefeller wie
eine Kapitalgesellschaft führen
[Musik]
sie verkauften in drei Monaten über
500.000 CDs
eine solide Grundlage um weiter zu
wachsen
sie waren sehr gut in dem was sie taten
sie machten eine super Promotion und die
Musik von Jessie war so gut was er das
Wichtigste ist und dann ging es richtig
los und wurde zu dieser Underground
Sensation
trat auch ein Klassenkamerad von Jaycee
auf
Christopher Wallace alias Notorious BIG
die beiden Rapper aus Brooklyn traten
oft zusammen auf bis zum 9 März 97
in der Nacht wurde notorious in Los
Angeles von einem Unbekannten Attentäter
erschossen
Jaycee war erschüttert aber es war auch
der Moment in dem er der prominenteste
Rapper des Landes wurde er war sehr
traurig weil er ihm sehr nahe gestanden
hat aber gleichzeitig wusste er dass es
eine erstklassige Gelegenheit war diese
Lücke zu füllen eine echte Stimme von
der Straße eine intelligente jazzys
wachsendes ansehen erregte die
Aufmerksamkeit der musikindustriegrößen
Russell Simons und Leo con und ihres
Plattenlabels death Jam
ich wollte Rockefeller in der Def
jam-familie haben einfach weil ich diese
Infrastruktur hatte
und ich brauchte wahnsinnig kreative
Leute um diese Infrastruktur zu nutzen
1997 kaufte Def Jam 50% von Rockefeller
Records für 1,5 Millionen Dollar
es war eine Partnerschaft 50/50 weshalb
wir ihn dabei das nächste Level zu
erreichen und es gab ihnen eine
Beteiligung und genau darum geht es bei
jayz und Beteiligung bei all seinen
Geschäften bekommt er immer etwas an dem
festhalten kann
doch dann kam ein seltener Fehltritt das
Album in my life Band 1
[Musik]
ich glaube das Problem war in my life
war kein besonders gutes Album Jessie
Klang plötzlich weicher um ein breiteres
Publikum zu erreichen
Hardcore Fans stellten seine
Glaubwürdigkeit in Frage
er sagte das Album sei ihm entglitten er
brauchte eine Wende und das schickte ihn
zurück in seine bewegte Vergangenheit
war ich meine das Album war sein
Thriller das war sein Michael Jackson
Thriller Album
das war sein erster crossoverhead und
das annie-thema in den Kontext des
mercy-projekts zu stellen ist ziemlich
brillant und es hat funktioniert das war
eine riesen Erfolg
es schadet nicht dass er eine irrsinnige
Arbeitsmoral hat er hat wirklich sehr
sehr hart daran gearbeitet das zu
kreieren und zu promoten und es hat sich
gelohnt hartnock live brachte Jay Z 1999
einen Grammy für das beste Rapper Moment
jayzee der Superstar war wieder da
es braucht so viel um voranzukommen um
von einem Unbekannten zu eine
Berühmtheit zu werden
und ich denke er war bereit die Firma
war bereit und die Fans waren bereit
die 50 City-Tour für hart noch live
brachte 18 Millionen Dollar ein das
Album weitere 5 Millionen
Ende 99 gründeten Jay Z und seine
Partner das Modelabel mit dem sie in 18
Monaten 80 Millionen Dollar umsetzen
er versuchte wie andere zu sein wie
Tiger und Pickens oder Donald Trump
sozusagen am Ende ging es ihm darum
irgendwo in den Hampton sein Haus zu
haben und einen Maibach zu fahren was er
tatsächlich auch Tat wissen Sie was ich
meine
was auch immer der Erfolg ihm gebracht
haben mochte Frieden war es nicht sein
Temperament kam plötzlich und heftig
wieder an die Oberfläche es war etwas
das nicht hätte passieren dürfen und er
würde die als erster sagen dass es ein
schwerer Fehler war mit 29 war jayz ein
Hip-Hop Superstar und Chef seines
eigenen Multimillionen Dollar
Unternehmens er hatte Jahre damit
verbracht sein Image zu pflegen
bis er am ersten Dezember 99 den
Produzenten Lance River in KitKat Club
in New York mit einem Messerangriff
era gut und vertraute ihn und als er von
angeblichen raumkopien hörte rammte er
ihm eine drei zollklänge in den Bauch er
hatte ihn gewarnt damit aufzuhören und
der Tat es nicht das alles in einem Raum
voller Zeugen er hatte alles zu
verlieren
wurde wegen Körperverletzung zweiten
Grades angeklagt er bekannte sich
schuldig und bekam drei Jahre auf
Bewährung
er hat fast alles durcheinander gebracht
aber er kam damit durch und sah aus als
wäre er der Teflon Rapper der Teflon
Rapper lernte dann seine Diamanten die
war Beyoncé
jahrelang vermieden Sie es über ihre
Beziehung zu sprechen
es hat lange gedauert bis er diese
Beziehung öffentlich bestätigt hat das
zeigt wie viel Angst der davor hatte zu
erkennen wie echt das war all dieses
Teflon musste entfernt und das Vertrauen
wieder aufgebaut werden sie ist die Frau
die in dieser Hinsicht das Unmögliche
geschafft hat
[Musik]
ich sein Privatleben beruhigte nahm sein
Geschäftsleben Fahrt auf mit mehr Hits
und Auszeichnungen
Ende 2001 erzielte seine Modelinie über
100 Millionen Dollar Umsatz
ein Jahr später machte jasie ein
schlagzeilenträchtiges Geschäft mit
Reebok
von translation
es gab noch nie einen nicht Sportler der
einen so großen Schuh Deal mit einer der
drei Topmarken abgeschlossen hatte Nike
Adidas Reebok wir verkauften innerhalb
einer Stunde 10.000 paar und dann bauten
wir 100 Millionen Dollar Franchise mit
dem Namen Skater auf
alles was er berührte schien Feuer zu
fahren
auch Beyonce
[Musik]
als ihr Album durchstartete schockierte
er seine Fans und verkündete seinen
Rückzug aus der Musik
weißt du ich bin zufrieden mit dem was
ich als Solo-Künstler erreicht habe ich
frage mich was könnte ich noch erreichen
ich glaube er wollte einfach für eine
Minute Abstand nehmen
er hatte das Gefühl alles getan zu haben
was er tun konnte
aber auf der anderen Seite wollte er
vielleicht auch sehen wie die Leute
darauf reagieren dass er in Rente geht
der größte lebende Rapper
sein Abschiedskonzert fällt to black im
November 2003 im Madison Square Garden
war sofort ausverkauft jetzt sollte das
Büro seine neue Bühne werden
[Musik]
2004 kaufte Def Jam die restlichen
Anteile an Rockefeller für 10 Millionen
Dollar
sie gaben bekannt dass Jason Präsident
und Vorstand von Def Jam werden würde
mit einem Dreijahresvertrag im Wert von
weiteren 8 bis 10 Millionen Dollar
[Musik]
wenn man sich seine Vergangenheit
ansieht gibt es viele Leute die ihm als
Mentoren zur Seite gestanden haben er
lernte alles was sie ihm zu beten hatten
und dann als er alles gelernt hatte und
er es nicht mehr brauchte ging er weiter
[Musik]
bis Ende 2004 hatte rockerwear 300
Millionen Dollar eingespielt
closing für 30 Millionen Dollar und
verkaufte sie anderthalb Jahre später
für 204 Millionen an den moderießen
iconics
der Typ ist ein Genie und jedes Mal wenn
er einen Deal macht ist der
wahrscheinlich der klügste Typ im Raum
im Hinterkopf denkt er weißt du ich habe
Geschäfte mit Leuten gemacht die viel
furchterregender sind als du er
beobachtete die Leute was sie tragen was
sie tun wie sie zucken wie sich ihr
Gesicht bewegt und dann wenn die Zeit
reif ist kommt er mit seiner Forderung
aber er fand noch eine weitere Rolle die
des Philanthropen anstatt nur Geld zu
verdienen begann er es zu verschenken
er gründete die
schornkaterstipendienstiftung für
bedürftige Studenten
2006 traf er sich mit Kofi anan bei der
UNO um auf eine Umweltkrise aufmerksam
zu machen die globale Wasserknappheit
alle 15 Sekunden steht ein Kind ich
freue mich sehr rauszugehen nicht nur
ein Rockstar zu sein sondern auch zu
helfen es hat ihn zu einem globalen
Botschafter gemacht seiner
Persönlichkeit eine neue Dimension
gegeben man kann ihn nicht mehr einfach
nur als Rapper bezeichnen
von Künstlern wie Rihanna nio und Young
Jesi aus und war aber auch bereit für
einen weiteren eigenen Hit drei Jahre
nach seinem Rückzug veröffentlichte er
Kingdom kam das Album verkaufte sich in
der ersten Woche über 680.000 mal
2007 endete sein Vertrag bei der Jam er
nahm die Rechte an seinen Aufnahmen mit
eine potenzielle Goldmine
als Geschäftsmann ist dass er genau weiß
wo er sein will und nicht entgleist er
ist opportunistisch war aber von Anfang
an auch sehr strategisch
er glaubt dass ein Geschäft nicht
erfolgreich ist wenn die andere Seite
nicht auch gewinnt er ist ein
win-win-typ
vielleicht neigt er dazu selbst etwas
mehr zu gewinnen seine langfristige
Strategie umfasste eine Reihe lukrativer
Werbeverträge mit den Konzernen Giganten
HP Budweiser Heineken und cook
er weiß sehr genau was er zu tun bereit
ist und was nicht er würde sein Image
seinen Namen und den guten Willen nie
für Geld für drehen oder Opfern jeder
wollte mit ihm Geschäfte machen
im April 2008 unterschrieb er beim
Konzert Giganten Live Nation einen
10-Jahresvertrag der Touren
Veröffentlichungen und Aufnahmen
als die Einnahmen der Plattenindustrie
rückläufig waren kam Live Nation mit
einem sogenannten 360 Deal auf Jason zu
was bedeutet dass sie ein Stück von
allem bekommen was er tut für Jazzy war
das brillant denn während der Kuchen in
der Musikindustrie immer kleiner wurde
bot dieses Unternehmen einen viel
größeren Kuchen und garantierte
Einnahmen sie nahmen einen Teil des
Risikos und die Belohnung war viel
größer in derselben Woche besiegelte er
einen weiteren Deal die Presse stellte
fest dass er und Beyoncé verheiratet
waren
heiraten ist das als würden BMW und
Mercedes zusammen gehen
das war die stärkste promi-marke der
Welt
und dann die neue New Yorker
Nationalhymne die Sinatra von seinem
Thron stieß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Album The Blue Prince schrieb
Musikgeschichte es war Jazz 11 Nummer 1
eine mehr als Elvis Presley der King
wurde von einem Hip Hopper überholt
[Musik]
hat ist einfach bemerkenswert
es würde ihn wirklich aus dem Reich des
Hip Hop und bringt ihn in die oberen
Ränge oder den höchsten Rang der
Popkultur
er ist jetzt 40 Jahre alt er könnte mit
50 Milliardär sein
wollte sich im Geschäft profilieren und
er wollte dass das noch lange nachwirkt
sein Ehrgeiz ist phänomenal und hat eine
wilde Geschwindigkeit
er ist schnell er ist wütend er wollte
schon lange ein Zeichen setzen das hat
diesen Kerl am Laufen gehalten
dass jemand der im Grunde eine Outlaw
Persönlichkeit war zum massenunterhalter
und Geschäftsmann wurde ist einfach eine
enorme Leistung
man hat ihn das Orakel von Omaha genannt
den Weisen von Nebraska und schon in
jungen Jahren wusste er dass er reich
werden würde als ich zehn Jahre alt war
war mir klar dass wir nicht ein langes
Leben habe am Ende viel Geld haben werde
und hinter seinem volkstümlichen
auftreten verbirgt sich einer der
gewieftesten und härtesten
Geschäftsmänner Amerika man macht keine
40 Milliarden Dollar indem man Mister
Rogers oder einer der Muppets ist Warren
geht über Leichen wenn es um eine
Verhandlung geht er nutzt jeden Hebel
den er hat
Warren Buffett hat die risikoreichen
Spekulationen der Wall Street gemieden
er lebt und arbeitet in Omaha wo er 1930
geboren wurde und wo seine Besessenheit
von allen finanziellen Dingen begann ich
wusste dass ich mich für den Rest meines
Lebens für Aktien interessieren würde
schon als ich acht oder neun war ich
führte Tabellen über alle möglichen
Aktien
schenkte mir einen Weltall mal nach und
so lernte ich die Bevölkerungszahlen
aller größeren Städte auswendig ich
mochte einfach Zahlen nicht nur
Wirtschaftszahlen
diese Zahlen zu merken sollte die
Grundlage für seinen späteren Erfolg
sein
Großvater hatte einen Lebensmittelladen
ich kaufte bei ihm Coca-Cola im
Sechserpack für einen Quarter und
verkaufte sie für einen Fünfer pro Stück
er verkaufte Zeitungen am Türen ich
hatte alle möglichen kleinen Projekte
nicht alle sehr erfolgreich aber ich
machte von klein auf gern Geschäfte
mit 16
School der Universität von Pennsylvania
ein wo er mit Charles Peterson zusammen
wohnte jeden Tag nach dem Unterricht
verbrachte ich so viele Stunden damit
Krieg zu studieren ich nahm die Bücher
in die Hand und saß da und blätterte
Seite für Seite
und er konnte in ein paar Wochen zwei
oder drei Kurse durcharbeiten
er hatte einen fotografisches Gedächtnis
ich nicht
Bafög entdeckte auch früh seine Liebe
zur Politik ich war Präsident des Clubs
der jungen Republikaner an der Uni von
Pennsylvania und kandidierte sogar
einmal als Delegierter für den
landeskongress als Republikaner
nachdem er das College beendet hatte
machte Buffett einen Abschluss an der
Columbia Business School und kehrte nach
Omaha zurück um sein eigenes Unternehmen
zu gründen er sagte ich werde eine
Gesellschaft gründen und er fragte
willst du mitmachen ich sagte natürlich
will ich zunächst waren wir nur sieben
oder acht Leute und noch weitere
Investoren zu überzeugen wurde schon
schwieriger eine Verkaufsgespräche waren
nicht sehr effektiv ich war 20 Jahre alt
sah aus wie 16 und nahm mich
wahrscheinlich wie ein zwölfjähriger ich
ging herum und sprach die Leute an sie
waren immer nett zu mir aber ich ging zu
irgendeinemann und erklärte ihm all
diese Fakten und Zahlen warum man Aktien
kaufen sollte wenn ich dann mit allem
durch war zählte ich bis drei also
3 und dann sagte der Mann was sagt ihr
Vater dazu ich hätte ihn hauen können
es war frustrierend wusste dass er ein
besserer Verkäufer werden musste also
wandte er sich an den bekannten
Selbsthilfe Guru den Carnegie ich musste
besser mit Menschen kommunizieren vor
allem in Gruppen ich wusste einfach dass
ich diese Angst vor öffentlichen
Auftritten loswerden musste und ich
hatte von diesem Dail Carnegie Kurs
gehört ich habe meiner Frau während
dieses Kurses an Heiratsantrag gemacht
also ich bin direkt auf meine Kosten
gekommen jetzt konnte Buffet endlich
seine Karriere in Gang bringen
er wählte Aktien aus die andere
ignorierten und seine Papiere stiegen
immer weiter nach und nach sprach sich
in Omaha herum dass der junge Mann
wusste was er tat
in den ersten fünf Jahren in denen
Buffett im Geschäft war stieg der DAU um
74% während um 250% zulegten
1961 im Alter von 30 Jahren wurde er
Millionär
aber das sah man seiner Familie nicht an
ihr Haus in dem Buffet immer noch lebt
kaufte er vor über 50 Jahren für 32.000
Dollar seine Kinder gingen alle auf
öffentliche Schulen
Susi Buffett ist das Älteste von drei
Kindern
wir sind auf einer Art aufgewachsen die
wahrscheinlich anders ist als die da
meisten Kinder die einen Vater haben der
das hat was mein Vater hat sie haben
keine Autos bekommen als wir 16 waren
wir haben nicht wirklich anders gelebt
als die meisten anderen Kinder die wir
konnten
die größte Veränderung im buffelt
Haushalt bestand darin dass Warren sich
vom Republikanismus seines Vaters
abwandte
die Bürgerrechte hatten den größten
Einfluss auf meiner Einstellung zur
Politik keine der beiden Parteien hat
sich unbedingt mit rumbekleckert die
Demokraten schienen sich darauf viel
mehr einzustellen als die Republikaner
mit Anfang 30
er eine Mehrheitsbeteiligung erwerben
konnte und erfand eines 100 Meilen
entfernt in Beatrice Nebraska
das war ein windmühlengeschäft tätig
Windmühlen sind ja heute wieder im
kommen aber vor 50 Jahren war das kein
gutes Geschäft die Aktien wurden sehr
billig gehandelt also kaufte ich welche
die ehemalige wallstreet-analystin Alice
Ruder ist die Autorin von der
Schneeballs autorisierte
Lebensgeschichte
es war ein Unternehmen das große
Lagerbestände aufgebaut hatte dies nicht
brauchte und die Belegschaft war viel zu
groß das Unternehmen musste einfach
verkleinert werden die Stadt in der es
war war sehr klein und es war der Haupt
Arbeitgeber
100 Menschen verloren ihren Job und
musste dafür gerade stehen was wollen
Buffett daraus gelernt hat ist dass er
sich nicht mehr in Unternehmen
einmischen wollte die Arbeitsprobleme
hatten in denen er Leute entlassen
musste in denen er sich persönlich in
das Management einmischen musste er
wollte dass jemand anderes das tut
nächste große Investition sah nach einem
möglichen Misserfolg aus eine
Textilfabrik namens Berkshire Hathaway
deren Aktien für 7 Dollar und 50 Cent
verkauft wurden wir haben einen
Textilunternehmen gekauft das wie jedes
andere Textilunternehmen in New England
dazu bestimmt war irgendwann zu
verschwinden das war ein Fehler ist
geschäftsführender Gesellschafter von
Tito Partners
Unternehmen sie hatten keinen
Wettbewerbsvorteil der es ihnen
ermöglichte eine ausreichende Rendite zu
erwirtschaften sie waren zwar ein
gewissem Maße profitabel aber diese
Rentabilität wurde unaufhaltsam kleiner
als das Geld aus Berkshire Hathaway
herausgezogen wurde wurde es
reinvestiert die erste große
Reinvestition die sehr profitabel war
war das Versicherungsgeschäft und das
trieb alles an was Berkshire Hathaway
von da am Tat
andre ist Reporter bei Bloomberg News
Unternehmen also von der Textil zur
Versicherungsbranche zum Teil deswegen
weil der Branche selbst Gewinne abwarf
aber auch weil Buffett die Prämien die
er von seinen Versicherungsnehmern bekam
wieder in Aktien investieren konnte
das nennt man the float die
Versicherungsprämien bringen zinslos
Geld ein das dann in andere Unternehmen
investiert wird
Bafög fand auch einen Partner der
genauso marktkundig war wie er Charlie
Manga der als Anwalt arbeitete als die
beiden sich kennenlernten als ich Warren
kennenlernte erzählte er mir wie viel
besser seine Lebensweise sei und dass
sie zu klug sei um in einem so dummen
Geschäft wieder Anwaltspraxis zu
arbeiten während ich wie er eine
investitionspartnerschaft leiten könnte
und ich brauchte etwa zwei oder drei
Jahre um zu erkennen er hatte recht
in den späten 60er Jahren erlebte die
Wall Street einen beispiellosen Boom die
Kurse schossen hoch und jeder stürzte
sich in den Aktienmarkt aber für Waffe
war es an der Zeit auszusteigen
ich hatte etwas mehr als 100 Millionen
Dollar und viele glückliche Partner
und ich schrieb ihnen einen Brief ich
sagte ich weiß nicht mehr wie ich dieses
Spiel spielen soll die Bewertungen sind
so gestiegen dass ich nichts mehr finden
kann ich beendete meine Partnerschaft
es scheint nicht intuitiv zu sein aber
Warren hat immer das Luigi zitiert der
sagte sei gierig wenn andere ängstlich
sind sei ängstlich wenn andere gierig
sind und waren wusste dass die Party
irgendwann zu Ende ist und die Blase
platzen wird
war 40 Jahre alt und über 25 Millionen
Dollar schwer
aber er war unruhig und traf 1973 die
schicksalhafte Entscheidung sich in eine
kalifornische Bank
einzukaufen das Problem war Wesco befand
sich mitten in einem fusionsgeschäft mit
einem anderen Unternehmen und dann
beschwerte sich das Unternehmen das
Wesco kaufen wollte bei der
Börsenaufsichtsbehörde Warren würde
versuchen ihre Fusion zu verhindern was
illegal gewesen wäre daraufhin wurde
eine Untersuchung eingeleitet die
Börsenaufsicht untersuchte jeden Winkel
von Buffets Geschäften
und Mangas Investitionen waren ein
komplexes Spinnennetz von Eigentum und
kreuzbeteiligungen wir waren da
hineingeraten weil wir mehrere
Unternehmen hatten das Ganze sah aus wie
eine Menge Spaghetti das für irgendeinen
bösen Zweck gemacht worden war
wir haben nicht das Gefühl dass wir
etwas Verbotenes getan hatten aber es
gab viele Regeln und die Frage ob wir
gegen welche verstoßen hatten
Stanleys borkin war
vollstreckungsdirektor bei der
Börsenaufsicht
immer wenn man feststellt dass Dinge so
verdrahtet sind dass es lange dauert bis
man sie versteht Stellen kommt der
Verdacht auf dass jemand das vielleicht
tut um mit etwas davon zu kommen
was die Ermittler ebenfalls stutzig
machte war die Tatsache dass Manga und
Buffett den Aktionären an der Westküste
einen höheren Preis für ihre Aktien
anboten als sie auf dem freien Markt
erzielen konnten also kauften wir
einfach weiter bis unser Kontingent
erschöpft war und zwar um zwei oder drei
Punkte höher als wir mussten das war
zwar sehr eigenwillig aber wir hielten
es für das Richtige und die
Börsenaufsicht drehte durch
um eine Katastrophe abzuwenden wandte
sich Buffets Anwalt mit einem
unorthodoxen Appell anständig
er sagte sie heißt denn auch wenn das in
deinen Augen nicht gut aussieht möchte
ich dass du dir den Charakter dieser
Person anguckst in meiner Meinung nach
wird er wahrscheinlich die Nummer eins
der finanzdienstleistungsbr bei aller
Zeiten in einem Financial Services
Industrie Award time wir Appell hatte
Erfolgsunternehmen wurde zu einer
100.000 dollar-strafe verurteilt aber es
wurde keine Anklage gegen Buffett
erhoben
[Musik]
der Aktienkurs von Berkshire Hathaway
stieg auf 93 Dollar
wobei die Gewinne vor allem auf das
Versicherungsgeschäft zurückzuführen
waren Bafög hatte auch Anteile an Banken
kleiderherstellern und Süßwaren Fabriken
aber bei einem Unternehmen war er
besonders leidenschaftlich ich liebe
Zeitungen ich habe angefangen zu lesen
wissen sie mein Vater brachte sie mit
nach Hause ich weiß nicht ob ich sechs
oder sieben oder acht war aber es war
das erste was ich mir schnappte meine
Schwestern auch
sein erster zeitungskauf war ein Omaha
Wochenblatt namens The Sun die Zeitung
gewann einen Pulitzerpreis eine seltene
Auszeichnung für ein kleines Blatt
dann begann er Aktien der Washington
postcom Pany zu kaufen die Zeitung war
nach dem Watergate-Skandal finanziell
angeschlagen
[Musik]
1973 waren die Aktien stark gefallen
[Applaus]
das Interessante ist als wir diesen
Stapel für 20 Dollar die Aktie kauften
wenn man die Leute die sie uns
verkauften gefragt hätte wie viel das
Unternehmen eigentlich wert ist hätten
sie gesagt 100 $ pro Aktie und sie haben
trotzdem verkauft ich bin der nächsten
Regierung auf ewig dankbar dass sie
damals den Staub aufgewirbelt hat
Bafög hatte sich immer von den
Führungskräften seines Unternehmens
ferngehalten Alexa aber das war bei der
Washington Posten nicht der Fall wo die
Verlegerin Katherine Graham seine
gesellschaftspartnerin und vertraute
wurde
[Musik]
sie Bahn einer Branche tätig die mich
faszinierte mich zu verschiedenen Partys
in Washington ein die sehr interessant
waren ich sah Teile der Welt die ich
sonst nicht gesehen hätte wenn wir nicht
Freunde geworden werden
aber während sich Buffets
gesellschaftlicher Kreis erweiterte
fühlte sich seine Frau Susi zu Hause
zunehmend isoliert und traf eine
Entscheidung sie ließ sich nicht von
Warren scheiden sondern ging nach San
Francisco um ein neues Leben zu beginnen
ich verstehe warum sie umgezogen ist
mein Vater wurde immer berühmter und
meine Mutter war so gar nicht der misses
wollen buffett-typ ihre Beziehung hat
sich nie verändert sie waren total
verliebt haben fünf sechs sieben acht
Mal am Tag miteinander gesprochen sind
zusammen verreist sie konnte bloß
einfach nicht hier leben
um sicherzustellen dass Warren in ihrer
Abwesenheit versorgt war wandte sich
Susi an ihre Freundin Astrid Mengs nach
ein paar Monaten
dogs eine Menge Leute haben sicher
darüber geredet und alle möglichen
netten Sachen darüber gesagt wie seltsam
das sei aber ich denke mir weißt du was
es geht niemanden was an was in der
Beziehung anderer passiert es hat für
die drei funktioniert es hat
funktioniert Buffett ging in die
Geschichte rein als er bei der Übernahme
der American broadcasting company durch
capital city half dem bis dahin größten
Medien Deal aber sein goldenes Händchen
reichte nicht aus als Buffett 700
Millionen Dollar in Solomon Brothers
investierte dem damals größten
Investmenthaus einige Jahre später
geriet Salomon in große Schwierigkeiten
es wurde brenzlig als ich im August 91
einen Anruf bekam man deutete mir an
welche Probleme auf mich zukam ein
Händler namens moscher hat er einige
sehr schlimme Dinge auf dem
us-staatsanleihenmarkt getan
zu diesem schlimmen Dingen gehörten
illegale Handlungen dieses der den
Anleihe Markt durch den Einsatz nicht
genehmigter konnten in die Enge trieb um
den Anteil von Solomon zu erhöhen und
die Konkurrenten zu verdrängen
war stellvertretender Vorsitzender bei
Solomon Brothers er war entsetzt über
das was geschah
mir war klar dass wir gegen das Gesetz
verstoßen haben wir hatten uns in die
Funktion eines wichtigen Marktes
eingemischt und die Zentralbank wäre
nicht begeistert
als Chef von Salomon Brothers
auf sich
ich erinnere mich lebhaft daran wenn man
es auf die Titelseite der New York Times
schafft mit Bild aber ein Dummkopf ist
das war ich wohl da wurde meine Notlage
landesweit bekannt das war
wahrscheinlich einer der schlimmsten
Tage meines Lebens
ich sagte Tom Strauß und John marry
Weber
von Solomon ihren Rücktritt angeboten
hat um einen Ausschluss des Unternehmens
als Haupthändler für Staatsanleihen zu
verhindern
einen letzten verzweifelten versucht das
Unternehmen zu retten indem er in Omaha
anrief und Buffet bat den Chefposten zu
übernehmen
wir hoffen dass ich das Vertrauen der
Leute gewinnen würde die wüten auf uns
waren und davon gab es jede Menge
die Krise verschärfte sich als
Finanzminister Nicolas Brady anordnete
das Solomon aus dem anleihergeschäft
aussteigt
morgen bekannt gegeben dass das
US-Finanzministerium uns von der Liste
der wirklich akzeptablen Leute der
primärhändler gestrichen hatte das wäre
der Todesstoß gewesen also musste ich
was tun und zwar bis zum Handelsstart in
Tokio
das war eine nationale Katastrophe
gewesen und es sah lange Zeit so aus als
würde die Regierung einfach sagen zum
Teufel mit dir Solomon
ganzen Tag mit verzweifelten Telefonaten
nach Washington um die Regierung zum
Rückzug zu bewegen ich war zu Tode
erschrocken und es hörte man mir
wahrscheinlich auch an viele Leute
wollten dass wir an diesem Wochenende
das Geschäft aufgeben und ich wusste
nicht was passieren würde gegen 23 Uhr
gab Minister Brady Solomon noch eine
Chance
um das Geschäft zu besiegeln musste
Buffet persönlich bei Solomon aufräumen
es war ein Elend ich war neun Monate und
vier Tage dort und es ist kein Zufall
dass ich 20 Jahre später genau sagen
kann wie lange ich dort war aber es war
wichtig das zu erledigen ich würde
niemanden wünschen was mit der Firma
passiert ist aber in gewisser Weise habe
ich viel gelernt
wurde zum Helden
Warren Buffett trifft sich mit der
Finanzgemeinde gibt Autogramme sie
lieben ihn der Mann mit dem
blitzsauberen Image der versucht das
Chaos bei Solomon Brothers zu beseitigen
1993 erreichte der Aktienkurs von
Berkshire Hathaway 17.000 $ und buffelt
berühmt aber keine noch so große
Weltreise konnte Buffets Gewohnheiten
lasst uns über Worms Ernährung sprechen
hier ist das Gemüse dass er ist
am Kolben Pommes Kartoffelpuffer und das
Obst wäre
bananencremetorte Erdbeerkuchen
ich glaube das war schon an Obst er
trinkt auch mehrere kirsch-cola am Tag
ich habe den Mann noch nie in meinem
Leben und das ist kein Witz einen
Schluck Wasser trinken sehen niemals
die 90er und 2000er Jahre waren die Zeit
der größten Expansion von Berkshire
Hathaway experience das Unternehmen
holte sich das größte Möbelhaus des
Landes
einen führenden Hersteller von
Wohnmobilen Fruit of the Loom Underwear
pains Derry Queen
insgesamt über 70 Unternehmen mit
250.000 Beschäftigten
einige Investitionen erschienen
unkonventionell
er kaufte die Zeitung seine Heimatstadt
den Omaha world Harald und die
Eisenbahngesellschaft Burlington
[Musik]
Buffett immer wieder gemacht hat wenn er
in etwas investiert dann schau die jeder
drauf und sagt ich habe es doch gesehen
warum habe ich das nicht gleich erkannt
in Omaha wurde die
Jahreshauptversammlung von Berkshire
Hathaway zu einer Pilgerstätte für
zehntausende von Aktionären was ist
wirklich erstaunlich das Stadion ist
voll und die Scheinwerfer sind auf
kleinen Klapptisch gerichtet an dem
280-jährige sitzen und diese beiden
80-jährigen haben mehr Ausdauer als alle
anderen im Raum
und Freitag bis Sonntagabend ist er
nonstop unterwegs und je länger das
Wochenende dauert desto mehr Energie hat
er
ich kann es nicht erklären es muss an
den Bürgern liegen
in den 2000er Jahren war buffelt zig
Milliarden Dollar wert
Geld dass er an eine Stiftung geben
wollte wie seine Frau Susi leiten sollte
doch 2004 starb Susi an einem
Schlaganfall nach einer Krebsoperation
es war ein großer Schock für uns alle
mein Vater ich kann nicht erklären wie
sehr er sie geliebt hat und wie sehr er
sich auf sie verlassen hat ich fange an
zu weinen wenn ich darüber rede
wissen sie er wird nie ganz darüber
hinwegkommen keiner von uns wird das
wahrscheinlich sie war wirklich etwas
ganz Besonderes
zwei Jahre nach dem Tod seiner Frau
heiratete Buffett Astrid Mengs bei einer
privaten Feier und gab bekannt dass er
den Großteil seines Vermögens nicht
seinen Kindern sondern der Stiftung von
Bill und Melinda Gates vermacht Bill
Gates ist seit den frühen 90er Jahren
einer von Buffets engsten Freunden
es war phänomenal wir konnten viel
ehrgeiziger an viele Dinge rangehen die
wir sonst nicht hätten tun können
es ist jedes Jahr ein gigantisches
Geschenk mit dem wir doppelt so
erfolgreich sein können wie wir es ohne
je gewesen wären
[Musik]
eine berühmte Persönlichkeit und ein
brillanter Geschäftsmann
als die US-amerikanische Wirtschaft 2008
in die Krise geriet war Buffet erneut
der Retter vieler Finanzinstitute die
unter den Schulden Bergen
zusammenbrachen
der darmschloss am Montag mit einem
Minus von mehr als 500 Punkten one
Buffett ist ein riesiges Gütesiegel für
gute Haushaltsführung wenn er Geld in
eine Sache steckt kann man davon
ausgehen dass er klug genug ist diese
Investition zu tätigen weil er glaubt
dass er damit eine gute Rendite erzielen
wird und das beruhigt die Leute wenn die
Angst am größten ist
zu den Unternehmen die von Warren
Buffett unterstützt wurden gehörten
Goldman Sex
und später die Bank of America aber
inzwischen ist Bafög über 80 und es
bleibt die Frage wer wird der Nachfolger
dieser finanzikone an der Spitze von
Berkshire Hathaway es wurde bereits
jemand gefunden aber sein Name noch
nicht veröffentlicht bin
jedoch verrät sind die politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Anliegen die ihm am
Herzen liegen
ich glaube in den letzten Jahren hatte
einige Sachen gesehen wo er dachte wenn
ich den Mund aufmache könnte das etwas
bewirkens was er am lautesten anspricht
sind die Ungerechtigkeiten des
Steuersystems tagsystem etwas das als
Regel bekannt wurde es gibt alle
möglichen Superreichen die normale
Steuern zahlen aber es gibt eine kleine
Gruppe die man sehr leicht finden kann
die sehr niedrige Steuern zahlt mich
angeschlossen
er schätzt sich glücklich zu diesem
Zeitpunkt der Geschichte in Amerika
geboren worden zu sein
ich glaube er ist einer der
eindrucksvollsten friedlichsten Menschen
die ich je getroffen habe er hat mit dem
was er getan hat viel bewegt und jeder
mit dem er zu tun hatte hat damit Geld
verdient und sein Leben verbessert
es gibt wirklich niemanden wie Warren
wir sollten uns zurücklehnen und von den
tiefgründigen Überlegungen profitieren
die er seit seiner Jugend über die
Wirtschaft angestellt hat
ich habe einfach jeden Tag eine tolle
zahl ich meine ich fange an genau das zu
tun was ich im Leben tun will
er ist rücksichtslos hartnäckig genial
Genius ein medienmagnet der ein globales
Imperium im Wert von mehr als 80
Milliarden Dollar Schuff er liebt das
Mediengeschäft er ist 24 Stunden am Tag
sieben Tage die Woche damit beschäftigt
er ist schläft und trinkt es Erfolg in
den Medien kommt nicht so leicht und
schnell
Rupert madok von News Korb ist ein
moderner pressebaron Herrscher über
Zeitungen und Zeitschriften
Fernsehsender und Kabelkanäle
Filmstudios und Satellitensysteme die
oft die Botschaft ihres provokanten und
polarisierenden Chats widerspiegeln
seine Redakteure wissen was Rupert will
und setzen das auch gerne um seit mehr
als 50 Jahren baut murdog sein reiches
Stück für Stück auf und löst dabei
Feuerstürme der kontroversen aus Rupert
Mörder ist die Verkörperung des Bösen
ist nicht mehr die angesehene Zeitung
die sie einmal war und einfach bittere
Rivalitäten
es ist ein zeitungskrieg es gibt immer
jemanden der sterben muss damit du leben
kannst und Rupert ist gut darin weil er
mehr Schmerz ertragen kann als jeder
andere
diese Kämpfe führten sein Unternehmen
von den Höhen des Erfolgs um den Rande
des Zusammenbruchs und wieder zurück
man könnte fast sagen er ist
größenwahnsinnig er will so viel
besitzen so viel Einfluss haben wir kann
er will der größte und beste sein den es
je gab oder geben wird
madok wurde schon als vieles bezeichnet
sogar in seinem eigenen Netzwerk ich bin
Rupert Mörder der tyrannische Milliardär
und das ist meine Skybox wenn du Rupert
Mörder bist beweise es
[Musik]
madox-präsenz im Film Fernsehen und
Printmedien ist in fast allen Teilen der
Welt zu spüren
Rupert murdok ist das was Gott meinte
als er einen Medienmanager schuf er hat
alle Eigenschaften die ein Medienmanager
braucht hier er hat Visionen er hat Mut
er geht Risiken ein und er geht an die
Grenzen
sein Imperium startete mit einer kleinen
Zeitung in Australien er wurde zu einem
der größten Medienunternehmen der Welt
mit über 150 Zeitungen internationalen
Fernsehsendern und einem Filmstudio
Movie Studio die News Corporation hat
einen jährlichen Umsatz von etwa 32
Milliarden Dollar der Mann der so viel
von dem kontrolliert was wir sehen
wollte nicht von uns interviewt werden
obwohl er seine politischen Ansichten
nie versteckt hat ich würde sagen
unterstützt die buschpolitik im Nahen
Osten auch wenn wir sein Vorgehen sehr
kritisch gesehen haben
extrem extrem
davon abhalten das zu bekommen und ich
glaube das war wahrscheinlich sein
ganzes Leben lang seinen Markenzeichen
der Anfang und der Kern seines Imperiums
die Zeitung
Michael Wolf ist der Autor von the man
who und the news dieser Mann ist im
Zeitungsgeschäft aufgewachsen er hat
darin Erfolg gefunden er liebt das
Zeitungsgeschäft ich habe Ihnen eine
Zeitung lesen sehen das ist ein
körperlicher Akt es ist zu körperlich
wie mit einer Frau Liebe zu machen
diese Besessenheit lag in seinen Genen
Rupert Mörder wurde am 11 märz 1931 als
Sohn des prominenten zeitungsmannes
zirkis Mörder und seiner Frau Lady
Elizabeth murdog geboren er wuchs auf
der Familienfarm außerhalb von Melbourne
Australien auf und besuchte das
exklusive Internat
ich weiß nicht ob es mir gefallen hat
oder nicht ich habe damals nicht darüber
nachgedacht aber die meisten
Erinnerungen sind sicherlich glücklich
aber er fühlte sich viel am Platz
umgeben von den Kindern der Melbourner
Elite Andrew Butcher war Vizepräsident
für Unternehmens Angelegenheiten und
Kommunikation bei newscore
aus einem privilegierten Umfeld aber
sein Vater besaß das Unternehmen nicht
indem er arbeitete er leitete es Rupert
sah sich selbst immer als Außenseiter er
blühte darin auf es gab ihm ein
Wettbewerbsvorteil
erhob sich noch weiter ab als er nach
Oxford ging wo seine Vorliebe für die
kommunistische Philosophie ihm einen
Spitznamen einbrachte der rote Rupert
das war wohl das Produkt seines
rebellischen Geistes ich bin sicher dass
er gegen seine Eltern rebellierte wo er
konnte und gegen die Werte seiner Eltern
so wie die meisten jungen Leute Mango
McKellen war ein junger Journalist in
Australien der später mit Mörder
zusammenarbeitet
damals vor allem von dem Wunsch
getrieben war dem Ruf seines Vaters
gerecht zu werden
es war eine angespannte Erziehung sein
Vater war ziemlich distanziert es war
schwer was freundliches aus ihm
herauszubekommen
zu seinem Vater und zu dem was er
erreicht hat
aber entschlossen
im Oktober 1952 als er an Oxford
studierte erfuhr murder das sein Vater
im Alter von 67 Jahren an Krebs und
Herzproblemen gestorben war als er nach
Hause zurückkehrte sah er wie seine
Mutter von dem Kollegen seines Vaters
unter Druck gesetzt wurde ihre
zeitungsbeteiligungen zu verkaufen
Rupert war entsetzt wie seine Mutter
behandelt wurde und über den Mangel an
Respekt gegenüber sein Vater nach dessen
Tod vom Verkauf bedroht war unter
anderem die News ein Boulevard mit einer
Auflage von nur 75.000
zurück nach Australien und übernahm die
Kontrolle
schon bald hatte er seine Finger in
allen Unternehmensbereichen
[Musik]
dass er die gleichen redaktionellen
Fähigkeiten hatte die alle anderen
1958 machte er seinen ersten Vorstoß in
ein anderes Medium das Fernsehen mit
Channel nein einem kleinen lokalen
Sender Peter Turnen ist ehemaliger
Präsident und schief Operating Officer
der News Corporation
Ende der 50er Anfang der 60er Jahre in
Australien an fernsehnetzwerk besaß und
das ist eines der Dinge die ihn hierher
brachten er hatte wiederholungsrechte
und Filmrechte von amerikanischen
Studios und Netzwerken gekauft
bald eine Reihe von Lokalzeitungen auf
darunter den Daily Mirror ein beliebtes
Boulevardblatt in Sydney
aber murdox ziel war es eine nationale
Zeitung zu gründen
1964 startete er sie Australian
man sagte ihnen das werde nicht
funktionieren die Entfernung sei zu groß
und es gäbe nicht genug nationale
Werbungen um das Blatt aufrecht zu
erhalten man sagte ihnen er werde auch
kein Personal finden weil kein guter
Journalist für eine Zeitung arbeiten
wolle die so eindeutig zum Scheitern
verurteilt sein
die Zeitung hatte von Anfang an eine
liberale Haltung und der verantwortliche
Mann war immer
präsentlich Rupert lief praktisch jeden
Abend im Büro auf und ab er ging dann
spät abends um 22 Uhr gegen
Redaktionsschluss in der Zeitung herum
meistens in so einem Leuchten gelben
Regenmantel und wurde gelegentlich von
einem der Mitarbeiter die ihn nicht so
gut kannten mit einer Reinigungskraft
verwechselt
über seine Zeitungen hat sich früh
durchgesetzt
ich mische mich schon sehr in die
Zeitungen ein aber ich glaube
andererseits lasse ich meinen
Redakteuren auch große Freiheiten im
Alter von 25 Jahren heiratete murder und
bekam eine Tochter prodence die Ehe
wurde nach elf Jahren geschieden
1967 heiratete er seine zweite Frau Emma
torff mit ihr bekam er in den nächsten
fünf Jahren drei Kinder Elizabeth
lachlen und James
ist seine Familie und seine Firma ich
glaube das sind diese Dinge die in
seinem Kopf absolut miteinander
verbunden sind mit dem Alter wurden
seine Ansichten konservativer
wurde mehr und mehr zum Gefangenen der
Geschäftswelt in Sydney
und wenn er in den Yachtclub ging
machten sich die anderen immer über ihn
lustig und fragten na wie geht's deinem
roten Lappen von der Zeitung Rupert
Rupert ist glaube ich vor allem an Macht
interessiert
man könnte fast sagen er ist
größenwahnsinnig er möchte so viel wie
möglich besitzen so viel wie möglich
beeinflussen der größte und beste sein
den es je gab oder geben wird
Ende der 60er Jahre war Rupert murdog
auf einem anderen Kontinent gelandet in
einem der wettbewerbsintensivsten merkte
der Welt er Definition des alten ist
Talismans
wo er auf den berüchtigten
Medienmagnaten robert Maxwell steht
es wurde murdox David gegen Maxwells
Goliath
of fing an gegen seine bekannten
Konkurrenten in den Kampf zu ziehen
man kann Ruperts Geschäftsstrategie als
zeitungsstrategie betrachten es ist ein
zeitungskrieg es gibt immer jemanden der
sterben muss damit man leben kann
mit einem Doppelschlag überlisten und
kaufte die beliebte und klatschsüchtige
News of the World und die schwächelnde
Tageszeitung des Sandes
baute sie in kürzester Zeit zu einem
Kraftwerk auf
waren vor allem Männer die eine
Kombination wollten aus Sport Sex
Skandalen ein bisschen Politik und oben
ohne Mädchen
liebten sie hat einen riesigen
kulturellen Einfluss gehabt sowohl zum
guten als auch zum Bösen sie hatte einen
Stil der die Öffentlichkeit für sehr
reale Themen sensibilisiert hat und sie
war natürlich ein fantastischer
kommerzieller Erfolg
jetzt hatte murdok eine neue Welt im
Visier die erobern wollte Amerika
er hat sich in Australien nie
wohlgefühlt oder auch nicht in
Großbritannien aber er kam hier an und
dachte sofort das ist mein Zuhause
1973 ließ sich mordog mit seiner Familie
in der wohlhabenden APA
er wollte expandieren aber um auf dem
US-Markt Fuß zu fassen musste er sich
mit einer kleinen Regionalzeitung
zufriedengeben
kann sie zu kaufen
eine nationale Präsenz also gründete er
eine Zeitung
um gegen den reißerischen national
enquirements
Supermärkten verkauft das heißt Sie
müssen für Frauen sein das war nie ein
richtig erfolgreiches Experiment
trotzdem verkaufte er später einen
aufgepeppten Star für 400 Millionen
Dollar an die Muttergesellschaft des
National enquira
doch dann war es ein Verblassen des
liberales Boulevardblatt das seine
Fantasie beflügelte die New York Post
die er 1976 für 30 Millionen Dollar
kaufte
wenig später erwarb er gegen den
Widerstand der Arbeitnehmer das New York
Magazine für 7,5 Millionen Dollar
inklusive der Liberalen village
es ist schwer sich eine Publikation
vorzustellen wie weniger zu Rupert
murder passt als die village
einen ansehnlichen Gewinn ab 8 Jahre
später verkaufte murder 55 Millionen
Dollar
maddock war jetzt auf den Plan in New
York im Januar 77 schmückte er das
Titelblatt des Timer gesehens 7 als King
Kong der über der Stadt wohnt und nach
den einflussreichsten Blättern greift
darunter auch die Posts
Martin singerman ist ehemaliger
Herausgeber der New York Post
die Zeitung lag im sterben wenn man so
will Rupert murdok investierte in das
Blatt sowohl finanziell als auch
personell
in people anderthalb Jahre später
investierten wir in neue Druckmaschinen
um der Zeitung Farbe zu geben
fügten Seiten hinzu und machten alles
was man tun würde und der Zeitung mehr
Substanz zu geben
dem Schlagzeilen der Inhalt Nachrichten
kombiniert wird
Zeitungen verkaufen sich über
Schlagzeilen aber langfristig müssen sie
auch Substanz haben die Leute kaufen Sie
nicht wenn Sie sie einmal angeschaut
haben und nichts finden es ist also
wirklich ein zweistufiger Prozess
die Post wurde sehr beliebt
auch finanziell war sie eine Katastrophe
und verlor jedes Jahr Millionen von
Dollar
Wirtschaftsjournalist von Grover
ich glaube nicht dass es Rupert unter
dem Strich nur darum geht zu gewinnen
ihm gefällt der Gedanke dass er dadurch
einen Platz am Tisch bekommt dass er
seine Position nach außen tragen kann
dass er Zugang zu Politikern bekommt
[Musik]
er beteuerte seinen Redakteuren große
Freiheiten einzuräumen aber diese
Botschaft kam nicht immer bei den
Mitarbeitern an Rupert schrieb
Schlagzeilen Rupert machte die Stories
Rupert diktierte die Geschichten Rupert
war einfach überall
jemand sagte zu ihm Mister Mörder dog da
gibt es einen Widerspruch sie sagten
dass sie ihren Redakteuren erlauben die
Zeitung zu leiten und er sagte das ist
kein Widerspruch ich kenne bloß die
Redakteure die ich einstelle
es gibt Rupert und dann gibt es die
Leute unter ihm er stellt gern Leute ein
die im dankbar dafür sind dass er sie
eingestellt hat solche auf deren
Loyalität erzählen kann stellt nicht
gerne Leute ein die mit ihm konkurrieren
könnten die das Gefühl haben könnten
dass sie auf der gleichen Ebene stehen
wie er
die Kontrolle die er über seine
Nachrichten Organisationen ausübt
besteht nicht wirklich darin dass er ins
Telefon schreit
man hat eher das Gefühl dass seine
Redakteure wissen was er will
[Musik]
ich würde nie für seine Zeitung Arbeiten
nicht in New York nicht in Washington
nicht in seinentonio das ist
schonendungen in 1985 kaufte
ein Geschäft von zentraler Bedeutung
denn es ist ein Crossover hier ist ein
Mann der in Verlagswesen tätig ist und
jetzt ein Filmstudio kaufen
250 Millionen für eine 50%ige
Beteiligung an dem Studium
es war schwierig die ersten 50% von
Davis zu kriegen aber dann bekamer die
anderen 50% für schlappe 325 Millionen
Dollar
und so Übernahme das gesamte Filmstudio
21 Century Fox eine multimillionsschwere
Anlage für knapp eine halbe Milliarde
Dollar
er hat mir mal gesagt dass die Filme der
Nervenkitzel sind man braucht die
Nervenkitzel wenn man den Rest des
Medienimperiums schon hat er braucht sie
weil auf diese Weise kreative Leute in
das Unternehmen kommen der Kitzel könnte
auch nachlassen vor allem im riskanten
Multimillionen Dollar Filmgeschäft movie
business
eines der großartigsten Dinge an Rupert
ist dass er in einer Krise der coolste
und ruhig ist
und wenn er dich unterstützt und hat
dich glaubt wird er immer hinter dir
stehen
weißt du wenn er an Dich glaubt und du
ehrlich zu ihm bist von der
Angemessenheit deiner Entscheidung
überzeugt ist er der beste Mann den du
dir in einem Schützengraben wünschen
kann
sein Unternehmen erweitern indem er sich
in den us-fernsehmaß einkaufen aber da
gab es ein ernsthaftes Problem es gibt
eine Vorschrift dass man Staatsbürger
der Vereinigten Staaten sein muss um
einen Fernsehsender zu besitzen und
Rupert der Prag beschloss wenn das nötig
ist werde ich eben US-Bürger am 4
September 85 wurde Rupert murdog
amerikanischer Staatsbürger
ist ehemaliger Vorstandsvorsitzender von
British Airways und ein enger Freund
als murrock seine australische
Staatsbürgerschaft aufgab um die
amerikanische aufzunehmen wurde er dafür
kritisiert aber das Unternehmen war nun
mal dort und der größte Markt ist in den
USA es ist nicht so dass er die
amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaft nur
angenommen hat um dort ein medienbaron
zu sein er hat sich entschieden sein
Leben in Amerika zu verbringen
er bezahlte John Clooney von Metro Media
bis zu zwei Milliarden Dollar um
Fernsehsender in sechs großen Märkten zu
kaufen
werden sollte
es gab
es und es gab keinen Platz für ein
weiteres Netzwerk und dann kommt gut
ein viertes Netzwerk
[Musik]
gab das jüngere Zuschauer anzieht und
eine größere Vielfalt anzuschauen
das ist die pieptaste wir gehen live
drauf und das heißt kein Piep die Late
Show mit Joan Rivers scheiterte kläglich
gegen den unerschütterlichen Johnny
Carson für das junge Team bei Fox eine
bittere Lektion Gareth Enzians der
ehemalige Präsident des Fernsehsenders
seit den 50er Jahren hatte niemand mehr
eine sendekette gegründet wir mussten
erstmal herausfinden wie ein Network
sein muss dass sich von NBC ABC und CDs
unterscheidet im Nachhinein scheint es
offensichtlich oh ja wenn du sendest
wenn sie es sendet dann wirst du keinen
Erfolg haben
Talente zu gewinnen wie die
Serienschöpfer James Brooks und diesen
kennen es gab kreative Freiheit und
sicherlich mehr als sie bei den anderen
Networks bekommen würden aber wir gaben
auch größere Aufträge sie setzten direkt
auf Serien weil wir das mussten wir
hatten ja nur ein Jahr Zeit um das Ganze
aufzubauen und zum Laufen zu bringen
mit einer Reihe von Sendungen die sich
gegen die Konkurrenz durchsetzen begann
der vierte Sender sich in den
Einschaltquoten zu machen
[Musik]
twenty one Jump Street young cobshow
Mary children irre Veron family Show ich
meine der Arbeitstitel von Mary children
war nicht die cosbies und living color
und all diese Dinge wurden viel mehr es
muss einfach anders sein als die Sachen
auf den anderen Kanälen und nichts war
so anders wie die Sendung die alles
verändern sollte der größte Wendepunkt
waren die Simpsons
Rupert hat es über alles geliebt den
Sendeplan zu erstellen er war wie ein
Kind in einem Süßwarenladen und ich habe
immer Witze darüber gemacht dass er
aufsprang und anfing Zettel an die Tafel
zu machen und zu fragen wie ist das und
wir meinten na ja nicht so richtig gut
dann hängt er etwas anderes hin aber
irgendwann sprang er auf und nahm die
Simpsons und stellte sie am
Donnerstagabend gegen die Cosby Show er
wollte diese winzige kleine Sendung mit
der wir gerade erst angefangen hatten
gegen die Nummer eins im Fernsehen
antreten lassen und zuerst dachten wir
ehrlich gesagt alle er sei verrückt sie
sagten das können wir nicht machen wir
werden vernichtet und er sagte immer
wieder vertraut mir das wird
funktionieren das Ding war zu 100%
rupertide
amerikanische Fernsehen expandierte er
löste er in London eine Revolte der
mächtigen britischen Presse
Gewerkschaften aus
das sollte die Hauptstadt der Zeitungen
sein und all die Arbeit ist durch die
Aktivitäten der Londoner Gewerkschaften
verloren gegangen um die
Zeitungsproduktion zu automatisieren
verlegte murdoxy von der Fleet Street in
einen Werk im Londoner Hafenviertel
wapping
das neue effiziente verbrauchte weniger
Arbeitskräfte über 5000 weniger
murder plante sie alle zu entlassen
als ehemalige Generalsekretärin der
britischen druckergewerkschaft zoggert
verhandelte
Baronesse zu retten
er war verständlicherweise der Meinung
dass er nicht mit den alten
Arbeitspraktiken aus der Fleet Street in
ein neues Werk umzieht dass diese alten
nicht brauchte
das war ein extrem radikales Abkommen im
Unternehmen aber das wird er nicht
bekommen wir waren immer noch bereit zu
verhandeln und er hörte zu und sagte am
Ende die Musik hat sich geändert aber
der Tanz bleibt derselbe
bereit seine geheime Abmachung mit der
elektrikergewerkschaft getroffen hatte
um schnell mit einer probedruckauflage
voranzukommen
[Musik]
bekam Unterstützung von einer alten
Freundin Margaret Thatcher die das
Management den Gewerkschaften vorzog er
hatte sie unterstützt als sie als
Premierministerin kandidierte und das
zeigte sich aus Regierung
Ellis Gesetze und in dem internationalen
Nachrichten Streit im Walking Streit ihr
bekannt wurde wurde die sogenannte
gewerkschaftsfeindliche Gesetzgebung zu
einem Schlüsselfaktor dafür dass Rupert
murdok bekam was er wollte
tausende kamen um die Proteste zu
unterstützen aber die Demonstrationen
nahmen eine gewalttätige Wendung
wurde die Festung genannt weil sie
wirklich eine war es gab
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen es wurde eine
murder-melits ausgerufen er wurde
dämonisiert
es gab ziemlich schreckliche Sachen dort
ich habe gesehen wie einige meiner
Mitglieder von der Polizei verprügelt
wurden es wurde Gewalt angewendet kein
Zweifel wir versuchten das zu
kontrollieren aber manchmal konnten
mit Hilfe von murdok die Gewerkschaften
und sein Werk in wupping war bald auf
dem vormar er ging ein großes ein und es
hat lange gedauert
für das Unternehmen
aber er hat am Ende bekommen was er
wollte
wer war der Boogieman derjenige der den
Arbeitern den Rücken brach es war ein
bahnbrechender Moment nicht nur in der
Geschichte der Arbeiterschaft sondern in
der Geschichte der Moderne selbst
er sagte das ist nicht vernünftig das
ist nicht logisch der Fortschritt
verlangt dass wir die Regeln ändern
und murdox Einkaufstour ging weiter
1988 kaufte er für 3 Milliarden Dollar
das annenberg-magazin Imperium mehr
gesehen Empire zudem auch seventeen the
racing Form und TV-Guide gehört zu
murdox schockierender Preis war der
höchste der je für ein Verlagshaus
gezahlt wurde doch dann wurde er durch
Vorschriften gestoppt
der Besitz einer Zeitung und eines
Fernsehsenders in einem einzigen Markt
waren untersagt madoch war gezwungen
seine Geliebte New York Post zu
verkaufen
Jahre später konnte er sie für 25
Millionen Dollar zurückkaufen nachdem er
eine Sondergenehmigung erhalten hatte
er hat die Post am Leben erhalten weil
er sie am Leben erhalten wollte niemand
sonst in der News Corporation wollte das
außer Rupert und die Leute die bei der
Post arbeiteten es macht den
wirtschaftlich
nach dem Himmel
großes Wagnis war das
Satellitenfernsehen David Hill damals
Spitzenmanager bei twenty first Century
Fox
das Sky Fernsehen zu starten gegen eine
hochfinanzierte etablierte Plattform
namens British satellite broadcasting
einem der größten Player aller Zeiten
das trieb das Unternehmen fast in den
Bankrott
das läutete die Explosion des Fernsehens
in ganz Europa und den Rest der Welt ein
1990 fusioniertes Sky mit British
satellite broadcast
blutete aus und murdok hatte sich durch
seine kauforgien bei den Gläubigern
gefährlich verschuldet glücklicherweise
beschlossen 145 Banken ihm mehr Zeit zu
geben eine Bank in Pittsburgh weigerte
sich jedoch und drohte einen Kredit von
10 Millionen Dollar einzufordern
hatte bestand darin dass wenn eine Bank
den Kredit einforderte alle anderen
Kredite auch völlig wurden mit einem
verzweifelten Anruf um 5:12 Uhr bei der
Bank in Pittsburgh rettete murdok sein
Unternehmen vor dem Zusammenbruch
das war diese unglaubliche Leistung mit
der es geschafft hat das Unternehmen zu
retten er musste Teile davon verkaufen
die Magazine er musste sich zu besseren
Geschäftspraktiken verpflichten die
Banken sagten ihm er musste sich
benehmen
er musste fast 8 Milliarden Dollar
Schulden umstrukturieren das war eine
Nahtoderfahrung für sein Unternehmen und
für Mördern vorher musste immer alles
ganz schnell gehen und jetzt war er viel
strukturierter
noch 1993 war er zurück am Pokertisch er
gab eine Milliarde Dollar für den
chinesischen Fernsehsender Star TV aus
ist ein amerikanischer medienanalyst und
Verleger
das Satellitenfernsehen dass er in
Hongkong aufbaute
dadurch hatte er in den frühen 90ern
breiten Zugang zu einem Medienmarkt der
dem Rest der westlichen Sender im Grunde
verschlossen war
am 1 September 93 spielte er diesen
Zugang murdok hielt eine Rede in London
in der telekommunikationstechnologie
haben sich als eindeutige Bedrohung für
totalitäre Regimes erwiesen überall
indem sie den privaten Besitz von
Satellitenschüsseln verboten und damit
auch Zugang zu Millionen Haushalten
Mörder musste die chinesische Regierung
besänftigen Namen die ungeliebte BBC vom
Sender und vernichtete ein China
kritisches Buch des Ex Gouverneurs von
Hongkong
die chinesische Führung war besänftigt
und murder chinesische Beamte zu
umwerben um die Präsenz von News Korb in
China auszuweisen
Scheine China ist die neue Welt das ist
die Zukunft und er hat das früher
erkannt als die meisten anderen aber
fast nichts funktioniert in China sein
Konkurrent war die chinesische Regierung
mit der chinesischen Regierung kann er
nicht konkurrieren
doch im Dezember 93 nahm er eine
amerikanische Obsession
Football und er traf mit einem
atemberaubenden Angebot von über
anderthalb Milliarden Dollar schnappte
er sich die Rechte an den National
ootball Spielen von CBS
ich glaube nicht dass wir jemals einen
Deal gemacht haben bei dem wir am
nächsten Morgen nicht mit
Gewissensbissen aufgewacht sind aber das
ist eigentlich gut denn es spornt dich
am noch härter zu arbeiten
für die NFL hätte das ein großer FuPa
sein können was
Football-Liga war sehr mutig denn Fox
hatte nichts keine Sportabteilung
wir sollten froh sein ich habe Fox Board
gesehen wir sind von Sport Singular sie
sind ein riesiges Risiko eingegangen was
würden Sie tun wenn Sie es vermasseln
wenn unsere Show vor dem Spiel ein
Scherbenhaufen gewesen wäre wenn das Set
auseinandergefallen wäre und dann wenn
die Übertragung beginnt wir die
Touchdowns verpassen oh wir haben es
nicht drauf die haben sogar liegen
falsch
[Musik]
und was wäre wenn er nicht alle
Amerikaner erreichen würde die Football
Leben murdok zuckte nicht mit der Wimper
er investierte weitere 500 Millionen
Dollar in New World communications
aus dem versierten Investoren
wechselte daraufhin mit 12 seiner
wichtigsten Fernsehsender zu Fox
es war die größte senderumstellung in
der Geschichte des US-Fernsehens und ein
Glücksfall für die lokalen Sender die
NFL auf FOX trinkt jährlich über 900
Millionen Dollar ein und hat bis zu 20
Millionen Zuschauer die Woche
Mörder war auf dem aufsteigenden
Wurzeln zurückkehren er fand sich in der
Fernsehbranche wieder gar nicht mag ich
glaube er hat nie eine volle Stunde
Fernsehen zur Haupt Sendezeit geguckt
aber er mag das Nachrichtengeschäft
Mitte der 90er Jahre wollte murder den
einzigen 24-stündigen Nachrichtensender
kaufen
Eigentümer
verachtete mörderpolitik und seine
Ansprüche und das beruhte auf
Gegenseitigkeit
[Applaus]
1996 ging der Sender im Rahmen einer 7,5
Milliarden Dollar Fusion mit Turner
Broadcasting an Time Warner
murder musste sich etwas anderes
einfallen lassen er ließ sich nicht
beirren und gründete seinen eigenen
Sender um sich mit CNN zu messen
etablierte sich schnell als Bühne für
konservative Ansichten
Publikum bemühen und man sollte das so
machen dass es billiger ist als Reporter
in die ganze Welt zu schicken
wir nur Kommentatoren und das
funktionierte und zwar unglaublich
cooler konservativer Politiker und
republikanischer Präsidenten von Richard
Nixon bis George Bush Rupert ist von
Natur aus konservativ vielleicht nicht
so konservativ wie Roger ales aber ihm
gefiel die Tatsache dass Roger einen
Plan für Fox News hatte Fox hatte zu
Beginn viel Geld verloren Rupert musste
sogar Kabelanbieter bezahlen damit sie
es übernehmen es war lebendig kontrovers
und machte die Liberalen Wahnsinn
Amerikaner und auch die ausländischen
Verbündeten die aktiv gegen unser
Militär Arbeiten sobald der Krieg
begonnen hat betrachte ich als
Staatsfeinde
mit dem Slogan
besteht der ehemalige Präsident und CEO
von News Korb Peter Turnen darauf das
Fox News seinen Unterschied zwischen
Nachrichten und
Talkshows es gibt Nachrichten bei Fox
News die tatsächlich sehr neutral und
moderat und fair präsentiert werden und
dann gibt es Talk und meinungs-shows von
denen niemand behauptet dass Sie
Nachrichten oder sachlich sind
eindeutig Leute auf der rechten Seite
des Spektrums sie wurden aber auch immer
als solche präsentiert
zum profitabelsten
kabel-nachrichtensender in den USA
doch in Murdocks Privatleben braute sich
etwas zusammen
1999 ließ er sich nach 32 Jahren von
seiner Frau Anna scheiden mit einer der
größten Abfindungen der Geschichte und
der 68-Jährige murdok heiratete direkt
die 30-Jährige Wendy dann eine
Absolventin der Yale School of
Management und ehemalige Vizepräsidentin
von Star TV Maddox persönliches Leben
schien wieder in Ordnung zu sein aber
weniger als ein Jahr später wurde bei
ihm Prostatakrebs diagnostiziert
euch bekam ein Kind und dann noch ein
weiteres
mit 70 Jahren bekam er seine Tochter
Grace und mit 72 seine Tochter Chloe
2003 im Alter von 72 Jahren zielte
murdok auf eine weitere fernsehtrophäe
direkt TV
er wollte schon seit einem Jahrzehnt ein
satellitengeschäft in den USA er
verhandelte fast zwei Jahre lang mit den
Vorstand von General Motors
an der gewann direct TV
sein 6,6 Milliarden Dollar Angebot
sicherte ihm einen Anteil von 34%. aber
eine bizarre Kette von Ereignissen zwang
ihn nur ein Jahr später dazu ihn wieder
aufzugeben während er 2004 die
Wiederwahl von George Bush feierte über
sah murdok das ein riesiges Aktienpaket
seines Unternehmens News Korb in
Australien auf den Markt kam
der us-medien-mogul John Malone
schnappte sie sich als sie in den
amerikanischen Markt übertragen wurden
Rupert wachte eines Morgens auf und
sagte heiliger Bimbam dieser Typ besitzt
16 Prozent meines Unternehmens er weiß
ja dass John Melonen ein cleverer
Geschäftsmann ist
Korb war nun der zweitgrößte nach murdox
um diesen Anteil an seinem Unternehmen
zurückzubekommen
loszuwerden musste er diesen Anteil
schließlich gegen direkt TV eintauschen
ich glaube er wollte vielleicht an
directv festhalten das war inzwischen
ein wirklich starker Programmanbieter
und Rupert hatte keine nationalen
Vertrieb das hätte ihm wahrscheinlich
gefallen
nachdem er seine Aktien zurückgewonnen
hatte kaufte murdog 2005 die
Internetplattform MySpace
um einen Konkurrenten auszusuchen
mit dem Internet ist eine komische
vielleicht aus seiner sich deine
tragisch komische
das war wissen Sie
ich glaube etwas mehr als 500 Millionen
Dollar es gab einen Zeitpunkt da wurde
sogar auf 25 Milliarden geschätzt und
jetzt was
der Versuch galt als Desaster
MySpace wurde von Facebook in den
Schatten gestellt also kehrte murdok auf
bekannteste Rahmen zurück und richtete
seinen Blick auf eine der angesehensten
Zeitungen der Welt
Sarah Allison ist Autorin von war at the
Wall Street Journal und war früher
Reporterin bei der Zeitung als ich mit
Leuten über Mörder und seine Vorliebe
für das Wall Street Journal sprach
sagten sogar seine Kinder sie könnten
sich an keine Zeit erinnern in der er
nicht über die Zeitung gesprochen hätte
und die Muttergesellschaft
einer prominenten Familie die sich eher
wenig Beteiligten hat schon drei mal
versucht das Wall Street Journal zu
kaufen
auf eine unglaublich hochmütiger Art
zum ersten Mal von dem Zerwürfnis in der
Bank Familie erfuhr der die Zeitung seit
über 100 Jahren gehörte setzte er schon
die Krallen
madok nutzte den Moment und machte ein
Angebot die Aktie wurde für 36 Dollar
gehandelt
ist ehemaliger Vizepräsident und
Direktor von Dow Jones
ich erinnere mich genau ich war
geschockt enttäuscht darüber dass mein
Journalismus mit dem Unternehmen enden
würde für das sich hart gearbeitet hatte
um gute Ausgaben für das Wall Street
Journal zu machen und dass sie von einem
Mann übernommen wird den ich nicht
wirklich bewunderte
erregende Angebot spaltete die bankraft
Familie noch mehr
da waren jetzt Kinder die drohten ihre
Eltern zu verklagen wenn sie an Murdock
verkaufen ich dachte es würde dem
Ansehen des Wall Street Journal schaden
wenn er die journalistischen Prinzipien
anwendet die er ja fast sein ganzes
Leben lang verfolgt hat nämlich seine
Feinde anzugreifen seine Ende zu
unterstützen und Politiker zu
unterstützen die ihm zu Vorteilen
verhelfen könnten
murdok versprach die Qualität der
Zeitung zu erhalten und die Mitarbeiter
zu übernehmen
unabhängig bleiben ich sag nichts mehr
ich habe gesehen dass er den Eigentümern
immer mehr Versprechen gemacht und sie
dann gebrochen hat er versprache würde
die Standards der times of London
beibehalten und an dem Redakteur Harry
Evans festhalten und innerhalb eines
Jahres hat er Evans gefeuert
doch kein Angebot war so attraktiv wie
murder 6 Milliarden Dollar
also gaben die Minecrafts nach am ersten
August 2007 schloss Dow Jones eine
Vereinbarung mit new score
[Musik]
ich habe seine Aufregung mitbekommen hat
dieses enorme Gefühl der Befriedigung
und er dachte über sein Leben noch er
wird wirklich Zeit mit diesem Journal
verbringen
nicht jeder war so begeistert davon
wir sind heute hier um allen zu sagen
dass Sie wissen sollten dass Rupert
Mörder das Wall Street Journal gekauft
hat wenig überraschend brach bald seine
Versprechen und holte seine eigenen
Leute rein
sozusagen durch die Hintertür die Kultur
mit einem Schlag kaputt zu machen und
das Ego der Leute die beim Wall Street
Channel arbeiteten
doch murdok überraschte viele seiner
Kritiker das Wallstreet Journal
überholte die USA Today und wurde zur
Nummer eins der Tageszeitungen in
Amerika
Rupert mörderk der Löwe im Winter wurde
2011 80 Jahre alt nach 60 Jahren an der
Spitze eines Medien Imperiums stellte
sich die Frage wer ihm nachfolgen würde
ich glaube er freut sich auf den Tag an
dem seine drei Kinder die sich für das
Unternehmen interessieren gemeinsam für
ihn arbeiten er freut sich auf den Tag
an dem es Rupert mal vier gibt kaufte
die Fernsehproduktionsfirma Schein
seiner Tochter Elizabeth für fast 700
Millionen
dollarin
kehrte nach einer erfolglosen Karriere
bei News Korb nach Australien zurück um
den Sendern Network kennenzulernen der
jüngste Sohn James wurde
stellvertretende Geschäftsführer beim
News Korb in New York wir sind sehr
wettbewerbsorientiert und zwar in dem
Maß dass wir dort wo wir Marktanteile
gewinnen müssen diese auch erobern
werden dieser wettbewerbsgeist sickerte
in die Unternehmenskultur ein mit
verheerenden Folgen
Medien enthüllten dass die
Boulevardzeitung News of the World die
Sprachnachrichten eines jungen
Mordopfers und ihrer Familie abhörte
und die Polizei für Informationen
bezahlte
Lewis anfangs wurde das als ein weiterer
kleiner schmutziger Skandal einiger
Journalisten angesehen die mit private
Detektiven zu weit gegangen waren aber
was wir für einen relativ begrenzten
Skandal hielten entpuppte sich als ein
allgegenwärtiger systematischer
Missbrauch journalistischer macht
auch die Handys von Prominenten und
Politikern wurden gehackt
stellte sich heraus dass dieses Telefon
hacking weit verbreitet war das ist
praktisch mit jedem gemacht wurde der
die Möglichkeit Boot Nachrichten oder
Klatsch zu liefern
um den Skandal einzudämmen wurde die 168
Jahre alte News of the World im Juli
2011 geschlossen
murdok entschuldigte sich vor einem
britischen Parlamentsausschuss
ich möchte nur eins sagen dies ist der
demütigste Tag meines Lebens seine
Mitarbeiter hätten ihn über das hacking
in die Irre geführt
Leute denen ich vertraut habe ich sage
nicht wer und ich weiß nicht wie oft sie
mich im Stich gelassen haben aber sie
haben sich schändlich Verhalten und das
Unternehmen und mich verraten
mitten in der Anhörung versuchte ein
Demonstrant mit deiner Torte anzugreifen
seine Frau Wendy beschützte ihn
der Skandal war schädlich und
kostspielig
James der Erbe trat als Vorsitzender
davon die Skype zurück und News Korb
zahlte über 380 Millionen Dollar an
Rechtskosten und vergleichszahlungen
zwei Jahre nachdem Wendy Murdock ihren
Mann verteidigt hatte reichte Rupert
murdok die Scheidung ein
er rief Fox Sports Network ins Leben um
mit ESPN zu konkurrieren und um die
Aktionäre zu besänftigen spaltete murdok
im Juni 2013 seinen sechs Jahrzehnte
altes Verlagsgeschäft vom Rest des
Medien Imperiums
das neue Unternehmen nimmt heute
offiziell den Handel auf es ist bereits
der größte Zeitungsverlag der
Vereinigten Staaten mit einem Marktwert
von 8,8 Milliarden Dollar
Rupert Mörder hat ein riesiges und
vielfältiges Imperium aufgebaut eine
konkurrenzlose und unaufhaltsame
Zentrale der macht dies ist ein Mann der
sowohl in wirtschaftlicher als auch in
politischer und kultureller Hinsicht
außerordentlich mächtig ist
[Musik]
Charakteristische an ihm was ihn zu
einem Presse Baron macht ist dieses
ständige Streben nach mehr und mehr
Macht fest und das ist es auch woran wir
uns erinnern werden
[Musik]